bien monsieur le rapporteur général
mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs
nous ne retrouvons donc ce matin pour
une table ronde sur les bilans bancaires
et les risques qui peuvent être associés
dans un contexte de hausse des taux
d'intérêt
la hausse des taux enclenchés depuis le
début de l'année 2022 par les
différentes banques centrales pour
lutter contre l'inflation
bien que moins brutale que celle mise en
oeuvre au début des années 80 par le
président de la Fed Paul Walker se
révèle malgré tout avoir des
conséquences sur le bilan des banques en
effet le prix des obligations qui
peuvent être à l'heure actifs varient
évidemment sans inverse de celui des
taux d'intérêt
l'exemple de la faillite de la Silicon
Valley Bank le 10 mars dernier est à cet
égard éclairant pilier du financement de
start-up de la tech cette banque avait
placé son surplus de liquidité né de la
pandémie dans des bombes du Trésor
américain de long terme plus
rémunérateur à la suite de la déroute
des valeurs de la tech en 2022 cette
banque a du liquider son portefeuille en
vendant notamment les obligations
souveraines qu'elle détenait mais qui
avait perdu de la valeur en raison de la
hausse des taux
cette opération a été à l'origine d'une
perte d'un virgule 8 milliard de dollars
donnant lieu un retrait massif de fonds
un débat existe quant à l'impact de la
dérégulation bancaire mise en place aux
États-Unis en 2018 qui a abouti à
relever le seuil à partir duquel les
banques sont considérées d'importance
systémiques sur cette faillite dans ces
conditions un risque de contagion à des
banques européennes qui n'ont toutefois
pas fait l'objet de la même dérégulation
c'est fait jour cette crainte s'est en
traduite par d'importants mouvements de
valeur boursière
le rachat dans des conditions
contestables de crédit Suisse une banque
impliquée dans de nombreuses scandales
et souffrant d'un contrôle des risques
déficients par UBS le 20 mars dernier à
raviver ses craintes encore renforcée
par la dégradation de la situation de
Dodge Bank quelques jours plus tard
dans ce contexte mouvementé la
Commission européenne a présenté le 18
avril dernier une proposition de réforme
du filet de sauvetage des banques qui
entend encouragé l'utilisation de fil de
sécurité financée par le secteur
bancaire pour protéger les déposants en
cas de défaillance de banque de petites
ou moyenne taille
Bruxelles argane effet que les États
membres tendent encore à recourir
davantage à l'argent des contribuables
plutôt qu'au système nationaux de
garantie des dépôts financés par le
secteur bancaire lui-même
allons de ces épisodes la nouvelle
hausse des taux directeurs de la BCE qui
intervient à compter d'aujourd'hui se
pose donc la question de la solidité des
bilans des banques françaises et
européennes de la viabilité des règles
en vigueur et de la pertinence d'une
évolution de celle-ci
alors pour nous éclairer sur ces enjeux
que nous avions déjà traité dans le
passé mais il y a quelques années
malheureusement je revienne
nous avons donc le plaisir d'accueillir
Monsieur François Louis Michaud
directeur exécutif de l'Autorité
bancaire européenne madame Évelyne massé
secrétaire général adjointe de
l'Autorité de contrôle prudentiel et de
résolution madame Maya TIG directrice
générale de la Fédération bancaire
française et Madame Laurence sialom
professeur d'économie à l'Université
Paris Nanterre et membre du conseil
scientifique d'ailleurs de la CPA
je vous rappelle que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat
je vous indique à chacun que
certains d'entre vous qui sont déjà
venus le savent qu'une intervention
luminaire d'environ 10 minutes vous est
proposé sachant que vous aurez ensuite
la capacité à la fois de répondre aux
questions de mes collègues et
éventuellement de compléter votre propos
si nécessaire
sans plus tarder donc je sais la parole
à Monsieur François lui Michaud pour
qu'il nous livre son analyse de la
situation actuelle et rappelle le rôle
de l'Autorité bancaire européenne dans
l'application des réglementation
bancaire
existantimez-vous que les bilans des
banques européennes sont toujours du
fragilisés par la hausse des taux nous
nous focaliserons davantage sur la
situation des banques françaises avec
Madame Macé merci monsieur le Président
et merci à la commission des finances
pour cette invitation nous sommes à
l'Autorité bancaire européenne
évidemment toujours très désireux de
d'expliquer notre action et de rendre
compte de ce que de ce que nous faisons
nous participons également à de
nombreuses auditions dans le cadre du
Parlement européen et sommes aussi très
désireux d'interagir avec les parlements
nationaux donc merci pour cette pour
cette invitation aujourd'hui peut-être
un mot tout d'abord pour rappeler le
rôle et le positionnement de l'Autorité
bancaire européenne au sein des du quai
dans le cadre institutionnel qui qui
régit la supervision et la
réglementation bancaire en Europe
l'Autorité bancaire européenne en fait
fait principalement deux choses à la
demande du législateur européen elle
elle définit des règles qui s'appliquent
aux banques des règles prudentielles et
également des règles qui s'appliquent
aux autorités qui contrôlent ces banques
et là elle crée un cadre général pour à
la fois la gestion des risques par les
banques et pour le contrôle de cette
gestion des risques par les autorités de
contrôle au niveau de l'Union européenne
dans son ensemble c'est à dire pour la
zone euro la Banque centrale européenne
depuis 2014 et l'établissement du
mécanisme de surveillance unique Banque
centrale européenne qui travaille
évidemment en liaison très étroite avec
les autorités compétentes nationales
comme la CPR pour ce qui est de la
France le contrôle des grandes banques
et donc est directement sous la
responsabilité de la du mécanisme de
surveillance unique
dirigé par la Banque centrale européenne
et le contrôle des plus petites banques
et sous l'autorité indirecte de la
Banque centrale européenne et sous le
taux et avec une action beaucoup plus
directe de l'Autorité de contrôle
prudentiel et de résolution en France
donc l'Autorité bancaire européenne dans
ce cadre fait donc défini des règles
pour les banques et ceux qui les
contrôlent et elles mènent aussi des
analyses transversales de risque de
façon à enrichir les travaux des
autorités de contrôle en particulier
elle mène tous les deux ans un stress
test un exercice de crise des banques de
la de l'Union européenne dans son
ensemble de façon très étroite avec les
mêmes stad façon très étroite avec les
autorités de contrôle qui reçoivent les
données des banques assure une la
qualité de ces données et qui ensuite
participe à la publication des résultats
nous sommes en train de mener un tel
exercice de stress test donc ou de
d'évaluations des bilans bancaires
depuis le début de l'année 2023 et nous
prévoyons de publier les résultats en
juillet 2023 ce sont des résultats qui
sont publiés banque par banque et qui
donneront une transparence au marché sur
la situation de de des grandes banques
de la de la zone euro nous couvrons un
échantillon de de banque très large donc
le stress test sera très pertinent dans
ce contexte
le un mot peut-être du du cadre
réglementaire européen par rapport au
cadre réglementaire américain et ce qui
s'est passé aux États-Unis avant d'en
venir à la situation plus précise du
système bancaire européen
la différence je crois que nous avons
une différence triple en ce qui concerne
ce que la situation que nous avons pu
observer aux États-Unis et les
situations que nous avons pu observer
que nous observons que nous connaissons
en Europe aux États-Unis nous avons pu
observer une triple défaillance en
quelque sorte une gestion des risques
insuffisante par cette institution la
Silicon valley-banque et quelques autres
puisqu'il y a eu plusieurs banques qui
ont été confrontés à des difficultés une
supervision qui de son propre aveu
reconnaît qu'elle a été également
défaillante la Réserve fédérale a publié
un rapport très clair en la matière et
également un cadre réglementaire qui
avait été très fortement allégée et qui
donc avait permis à la situation que
nous avons pu observer de ce de se
déployer par contraste au sein de
l'Union européenne nous avons une
réglementation bancaire depuis la grande
crise financière de 2007-2008 et la
crise de l'euro en 2011-2012 qui s'est
extrêmement renforcer avec une
supervision qui est beaucoup plus
systématique et qui est parfois
critiquée pour ne pas être assez
proportionné ou proportionnelle mais qui
d'une certaine manière nous nous rend
bien service en l'espèce et puis
également donc une gestion des risques
par les par les banques qui est
certainement de meilleure qualité que
celle qui a pu être observée dans le cas
de cette défaillance bancaire américaine
le cadre européen a été renforcé très
fortement depuis depuis la dernière
crise et il a été renforcé donc sous le
par différentes comment dire générations
de textes la dernière en date étant le
ce qu'on appelle le paquet bancaire
proposé par la Commission européenne
pour la transposition totale des accords
de balle 3 l'accord de bal 3 a été mise
en oeuvre par morceaux depuis plusieurs
années et là nous arrivons à la dernière
dernière tranche de ces de cette mise en
œuvre qui devrait aboutir très
prochainement
donc la supervision le cadre
réglementaire est beaucoup plus strict
en Europe la supervision est également
beaucoup plus systématique et là et la
gestion des risques tels que la
supervision peut l'apprécier et
certainement de meilleure qualité mais
je laisserai évidemment Evelyne masse se
prononcer plus sur ces sur ces sujets
nous sommes dans un cadre comme vous le
disiez monsieur le Président de remonter
des taux de remonter des taux forts
rapides certes moins rapide que celui
que nous avions vu sous la présidence de
Paul Walker mais néanmoins nous sommes
dans un cadre de remontée des taux forts
avec un décalage au niveau de l'Union de
la zone euro et d'autres membres de
l'Union européenne par rapport à ce que
nous pouvons observer aux États-Unis
mais néanmoins nous sommes dans un dans
un contexte de lutte contre l'inflation
très très volontariste l'objectif est
vraiment par les autorités monétaires et
vraiment de de mettre fin aux tensions
inflationniste et donc de peser sur la
sur la demande de la globale et cette
action va évidemment produire des effets
sur l'économie réelle cette action va
produire des effets sur l'économie
réelle et donc va se transmettre sur le
bilan des banques et aucun doute
là-dessus donc la question à ce stade
est évidemment de savoir quels sont
lesquelles est la capacité d'absorption
des bilans bancaires dans ce contexte et
je pense que le point de départ que nous
observons est un point départ solide
puisque les banques n'ont jamais été
aussi fortement capitalisées
depuis la crise de la grande crise
financière leur niveau de fonds propres
de nos fonds propres de meilleure
qualité ce que l'on appelle le
City One dans le dans le jargon est très
élevé il dépasse 15%, les niveaux de
ratio de liquidité sont également très
élevées
les effets de levier sont n'ont jamais
été plus aussi faible donc nous partons
d'une situation solide et les créances
douteuses le stock de créances douteuses
aussi a été réduit avant la crise du
covid grâce à une action très très
volontariste
des autorités réglementaires et encore
plus des superviseurs donc nous avons un
point de départ solide pour faire face à
cette à cette situation de remonter des
taux qui va évidemment avoir un impact
sur l'économie réelle et donc sur le sur
le bilan des banques
là dans ce contexte la
remontée des taux va produire des effets
et nous commençons déjà à revoir les
premiers les premiers signes le nombre
des faillites en Europe depuis le
dernier trimestre 2022 a augmenté nous
voyons aussi une augmentation des
provisions des banques depuis l'automne
de 2022 nous voyons également donc une
douce érosion d'une certaine manière des
des ratios des ratios bancaires mais qui
restent à un niveau comme je le disais
très élevé de la même manière les coûts
de refinancement des banques vont
augmenter
les coûts au financement des banques
vont augmenter à la fois quand elle lève
des financements sur le marché du
financement de gros auprès des
entreprises auprès d'autres institutions
financières mais potentiellement
également aussi quand elles vont devoir
continuer à garder leurs bases de
déposant peut-être en leur offrant une
meilleure rémunération parce que
certains déposants vont évidemment se
rendre compte de la de la situation
des taux et vont chercher une
rémunération plus forte donc il peut y
avoir une petite concurrence entre les
banques également pour garder leur base
de déposant la plus stable les déposants
particuliers donc nous avons ce contexte
et puis il y a une grande évidemment une
grande une grande question qui est celle
de la gestion active passif des banques
les banques évidemment ont octroyées des
prêts notamment des prêts immobiliers
des prêts immobiliers commerciaux à des
conditions qui peuvent être d'une celles
de taux fixe dans un contexte où leur
coût de refinancement à elle vont
augmenter donc il peut y avoir un
décalage donc toute la question qui se
pose pour les banques et pour leurs
autorités de contrôle c'est celle de
l'adéquation de cette gestion actif
passif par les banques qui a été comme
nous l'avons vu très défaillante dans le
cas de la Silicon valley-banque
dans ce contexte monsieur une petite
minute oui j'en arrive à la à la fin
dans ce contexte des travaux
ont été menés en fait au niveau des
autorités réglementaires et des
autorités de contrôle depuis plus d'un
an en amont de la de la remontée des
taux par la Banque centrale européenne
pour se préparer à cette évolution des
analyses en sensibilité ont été
effectuées des analyses de risques
poussées ont été menés le contexte aussi
de la du remboursement des facilités
octroyées par la Banque centrale
européenne a été étudiée de façon à voir
dans quelle mesure les banques
pourraient substituer ce financement
qu'elles obtenaient de la Banque
centrale européenne par des financements
de marché donc je pense qu'il y a une
grande une grande préparation depuis
plus d'un an le stress test que nous
allons publier également en Europe fin
juillet donnera un détail par secteur
des expositions des banques pour voir
dans quel secteur leur bilan sont le
plus le plus en risque mais pour le
moment je dois dire que la situation
paresse solide ce qu'il reste et ce sera
mon dernier point c'est évidemment
toujours le risque de d'une volatilité
de marché qui crée en fait un phénomène
de contagion et dans ce contexte nous
l'avons vu et vous mentionné Deutsche
Bank il peut y avoir une fuite des
dépôts très rapides
les ratios de liquidité peuvent être
très élevés si la confiance disparaît
les les la comment dire la fuite des
dépôts peut-être rapide mais il y a des
instruments pour pour y faire face et
nous avons vu qu'il n'y a pas eu de
contagion malgré les tentatives du
marché et les actions spéculatives qui
se sont déployées il n'y a pas eu de
contagion systématique au niveau
européen donc tout ça aussi nous donne
confiance je vais m'arrêter là pour le
moment
merci beaucoup
je vais donc proposer comme vous le
suggériez à Madame Macé de nous donner
la version plus française du même sujet
monsieur le
président le rapporteur général mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
tout d'abord un grand merci pour votre
invitation alors avant d'aborder la
situation particulière des
établissements français et un petit
regard sur les normes prudentielles qui
s'appliquent aujourd'hui à eux je pense
que c'est effectivement important comme
l'a fait avant moi François Louis
Michaud de revenir sur les causes des
turbulences qui ont affecté certaines
banques
américaines et le groupe Crédit Suisse
en effet
ces problèmes découlent au premier lieu
des défaillances de leur modèle
économique et de leur dispositif de
gestion des risques notamment en matière
de risque de concentration de taux et de
liquidités à cet égard le défaut de
silicone va les banques représente un
cas d'école la banque était en effet
excessivement concentrée à trois égards
sur le secteur technologique en termes
de clientèle sur un nombre limité de
grands déposants corporate en termes de
ressources de financement et sur une
classe particulière d'actifs liquide en
fait pour un montant qui était supérieur
à la moitié totale des dépôts du total
des dépôts à savoir des bons du Trésor
américain comptabilisés au coût amorti
ce qui a masqué les pertes la tente
associée
la rapide remontait des taux ou
traatlantiques a conduit les clients de
la banque SVB à retirer leurs dépôt soit
pour les placer ailleurs chez les mieux
offrants soit pour financer leur
activité les levées de fonds devenant
plus difficile sur ce secteur alors même
que dans le même temps la valeur de
marché des actifs liquides que
l'établissement pouvait mobiliser pour
rembourser ses dépôts chuter d'où la
matérialisation des pertes jusqu'ici
l'attentes et le défaut de la banque
quant à crédit Suisse s'il a panique du
mois de mars et une communication
particulièrement maladroite de son
principal actionnaire lui ont porté le
coût final en 2023 ce sont bien les
défaillances de son modèle d'affaires et
sa gestion des risques qui avait sapé
depuis des mois la confiance de sa
clientèle et occasionnée des sorties
massives de fonds
si on regarde simplement le quatrième
trimestre 2023 plus de 110 milliards de
francs suisses
à la différence de ces établissements si
on se penche sur les établissements de
crédit français il bénéficie d'un modèle
d'activité diversifiée et on
considérablement renforcé leur structure
financière depuis la crise de 2008 ils
ont d'ailleurs traversé avec succès les
deux périodes de stress précédentes qui
n'étaient pas négligeable la crise covid
bien sûr et les conséquences du conflit
russeau ukrainien
démontrant la résilience de leur modèle
d'affaires et leurs capacité à faire
face à des conditions de marché parfois
très instable
leurs courbes boursiers n'ont ainsi été
que on va dire modérément affecté par
les turbulences récentes pour revenir
plus précisément à la situation des
banques françaises sur peut-être trois
points en particulier
alors modèle à faire aucun de nos
établissements ne s'est ainsi spécialisé
sur le secteur technologique ils
affichent des résultats 2022 d'ailleurs
solides même s'il est vrai comme la
souligner d'ailleurs François Louis
Michaud que le renchérissement du coût
des ressources fera pression sur leur
rentabilité en 2023
en termes de liquidité leur source de
financement sont diversifiées et
globalement stables la réserve leur
réserve d'actifs liquides et largement
constituée à plus de 75% de dépôt en
banque centrale donc sans risque à la
différence du ksvb au final les
exigences réglementaires de liquidité
sont donc couvertes de façon
satisfaisante
si nous nous penchons sur le risque de
taux voilà pouvant affecter les titres
de créances c'est important de souligner
que pour les établissements français la
Vasse majorité des obligations détenus
et valorisées à juste valeur comme on
dit pas résultat ou par capitaux propres
très concrètement ça veut dire que c'est
moins value latente en fait elles sont
déjà déduites de la valeur comptable et
donc c'est bien intégré dans les calculs
prudentiels si on regarde la part des
des obligations qui sont valorisées au
coût amorti et qu'on la compare au fonds
propres les plus dures en fait ça ne
représente que
1,8%. et deux surcroît c'est moins value
latente elles sont déduites du calcul du
ratio de liquidité court terme le fameux
LCR donc ça pour vous dire que c'est un
élément qui a la différence de SVB est
très bien intégrée
alors par ailleurs en termes de risque
de taux elle passe avec succès le test
de résistance en fait on regarde on
simule une hausse de deux points de base
des taux de deux points pardon des taux
et elle le passe tout avec succès à la
différence SVB si on en croit l'une de
ces communications fin 2021 ne passez
pas du tout ce test et de loin alors
c'est constat rassurant concernant le
secteur bancaire français nous empêche
pas de commencer à attirer des leçons
des événements récents en matière de
réglementation de supervision et de
résolution en effet on a un triple
message
premièrement comme c'est déjà le cas en
Europe et François Louis il a rappelé il
convient d'appliquer pleinement les
principes Valois partout y compris aux
petites banques
en effet on l'a déjà dit les banques
américaines défaillantes n'étaient pas
soumises en fait à l'ensemble de ses
principales lois et en particulier à
certaines exigences en matière de
liquidité de risque de taux
comme j'ai déjà dit SCR aurait été voilà
en infraction à ce ratio de liquidité
court terme le LCR elle ne passait pas
non plus le test annuel de risque de
taux
proportionnalité ce n'est pas ne rien
faire pour les petites banques c'est
simplifier sélectivement certains
aspects en incluant une marge de
prudence car qui dit plus simple dit
plus on va dire frustre et donc il faut
être un petit peu plus prudent toutes
nos banques y compris les plus modestes
en France et ça couvre à peu près enfin
plusieurs dizaines des établissements
sont soumises à ce ratio assez ratio de
liquidité et à ces tests en matière de
taux
alors deuxième message je ne tourne un
petit peu vers le sujet de la
supervision alors il faut pratiquer
comme nous le faisons déjà en France à
la CPR mais plus largement au sein du
mécanisme supervisions unique une
supervision intrusive qui s'appuie sur
un faisceau d'outils pour analyser les
risques auxquels sont confrontés les
établissements alors le faisceau
d'outils bien sûr il y a des indicateurs
quantitatifs mais à surtout beaucoup
d'analyses beaucoup plus qualitatives
des comparaisons des simulations en
particulier les fameux stress tests
européens qui sont un élément central
qu'on mène tous les deux ans des
inspections sur place
certes les exigences réglementaires
minimales constituent un filet de
sécurité mais le vrai travail de
Supérion c'est de regarder au-delà pour
comprendre finement le modèle économique
et le profil de risque des
établissements à la CPA en collaboration
étroite avec nos collègues du MSU dès
l'été 2022 nous avons analysé les
conséquences possibles de la remontée
des taux et d'une liquidité
progressivement moins abondante pour
justement s'assurer que les
établissements l'avaient bien anticipé
dernier point la résolution
il nous semble que les turbulences du
mois de mars doivent nous amener à
réfléchir peut-être approfondir certains
aspects en particulier l'épisode du
Crédit Suisse nous rappelle que dans les
situations de crises les problèmes de
liquidité constitue souvent la première
et urgente difficulté à surmonter là où
notre boîte à outils réglementaire
actuelle permet plutôt de renflouer en
fonds propres les établissements
le cas des banques régionales
américaines quant à lui nous rappelle
toute utilité d'assurer une sortie
cohérente et ordonnée du marché d'un
établissement non viable même de taille
plus modeste
et à cet égard il nous semble que la
récente enfin sur ce point particulier
il me semble que la dernière proposition
de la Commission européenne sur le cadre
de gestion de crise et de résolution
pointe dans une bonne direction alors
pour conclure je voudrais souligner deux
nouveaux que le secteur bancaire
français ne présente pas du tout le même
profil de risque que les banques
défaillantes
aux États-Unis ou le groupe Crédit
Suisse à mon démontrer sa résilience
voilà ces dernières années ces derniers
mois les turbulences récentes ne
remettent pas en cause le cadre
réglementaire actuel mais souligne
l'importance des aspects de mise en
oeuvre de ce cadre qu'il s'agisse du
champ d'application des modalités de
supervision et bien sûr des outils à la
disposition des autorités merci beaucoup
pour votre attention
merci Madame pour cette position de
l'ACPL de manière générale
donc je me tourne maintenant vers madame
mayatigue
qui pourra nous présenter de son point
de vue la situation des banques
françaises
qui souligne d'ailleurs
fréquemment leur solidité
des banques ça vient
indiquer mais de votre point de vue sur
quels éléments vous appuyez-vous pour
l'affirmer
et peut-être également pourriez-vous
nous présenter votre regard sur les
récentes propositions de la Commission
en complément
président monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs pour votre invitation je
rejoins ce qui a été dit sur le fait
qu'il est essentiel au fond dans ce type
de situation de turbulence de pouvoir
prendre le temps d'analyser ce qui s'est
passé et d'expliquer au fond comment les
mécanismes ont pu s'enchaîner et en
rendre compte devant la représentation
nationale tout d'abord je compléterai
tout simplement ce qui a été dit parce
que au fond je n'ai pas de point de vue
à donner sur la situation des banques
c'est à dire que ce que j'ai à dire tout
d'abord c'est que ce qu'on dit les
autorités de contrôle se basent sur ce
qu'elle collecte de manière continue
constante ce qui a été dit auprès des
institutions ce qui est publié très
régulièrement également par les banques
et donc sur cette ce sujet de solidité
ou de capacité à avoir passé cette crise
ce qui a été indiqué est basé sur des
éléments purement factuels donc ce n'est
pas une opinion en peut-être ai-je une
grille d'analyse à donner pour cela qui
est largement la même sur la question de
la diversification et je dois dire que
nous avons en France un modèle qui est
singulier et c'est une chose dont on
n'est pas forcément conscient quand on
est quand on est dans l'Hexagone tout
simplement
notre en fait nous sommes au sein des
pays d'Europe celui qui a
essentiellement de grandes banques il y
a également des banques de petites
tailles mais nous sommes le pays dans
lequel proportionnellement les banques
les grandes banques les banques
universelles font le plus d'activités le
plus d'activités et donc ces grandes
banques elles ont aussi une forme
d'homogénéité dans leur caractère
universel j'y reviendrai et dans leur
solidité alors ce sont des grandes
banques mais également avec une volonté
et c'est peut-être le point sur lequel
je compléterai ce qu'on dit monsieur
chaud et Evelyne massé c'est que comment
dire il y a des logiques
entrepreneuriales également qui
expliquent tout cela et ça a été dit
d'une certaine manière c'est à dire que
la supervision si nous étions venus je
pense avec les copies papiers des règles
j'étais en train de c'est plusieurs
centaines de pages de directives et des
milliers voire dizaines de milliers de
normes de l'Autorité bancaire européenne
sans même parler des livres de
traduction interne de tout cela et donc
je pense que pour tout ce qui est
d'ailleurs les professeurs doivent avoir
forte à faire pour absorber tout cela et
je dois dire que ça conduit au sein des
établissements d'une part d'abord à des
recrutements importants à un
renforcement des équipes de l'ordre de
15% des recrutements que nous faisons
chaque année sont liés à la gestion des
risques et donc c'est quand même un
élément important entre 10 et 15% et
puis c'est une part importante des
effectifs à une spécialisation mais
aussi à la profiter de donner également
une dimension entrepreneuriale à cette
activité c'est à dire que respecter les
règles il n'y a pas le choix c'est
important il faut le faire faire décider
la gouvernance sur le niveau de risque
acceptable c'est essentiel et pour cela
la gouvernance doit s'approprier ses
règles et puis il faut également mettre
en cohérence des règles qui sont parfois
contradictoires entre elles ou qui
parfois conduirait à des décisions
contraires et donc vous devez je prends
un exemple si les règles conduisaient à
uniquement acheter des titres d'État et
j'imagine bien que les superviseurs de
SVB trouvaient que c'était bien et qui
serait inattaquable en achetant des
titres d'État mais c'est très facile
sauf que si vous ne prenez pas en compte
le risque que ça peut entraîner en cas
de hausse des taux mais vous n'avez pas
bien fait votre travail vous avez
appliqué les règles linéairement mais
vous n'avez pas fait la synthèse de tout
donc tout cela le simple point sur
lequel je voulais compléter ce qui a été
dit sur la résilience de notre le
secteur la solidité pour vous répondre
monsieur le Président un ratio de
solvabilité
donc cœur de 15,34% versus des minimas
qui sont compris entre 9 et 10%. donc on
est largement au dessus et puis un ratio
de liquidité de 164 % pour des mini-mats
de l'or enfin minima de 100% comme son
ratio le suppose et bien en réalité
c'est à la fois le fruit de cette
régulation de cette supervision mais
aussi d'une gestion dont on voit que
quand elle est défaillante elle pose de
réelles difficultés j'ajoute également
un point à l'analyse qui est l'absence
de contagion
l'absence de
l'absence de contagion est liée tout
simplement au fait que depuis la crise
de 2008 on est dans une situation
totalement différente c'est à dire que
les interdépendances entre banque sont
beaucoup moins fortes quand on regarde
la part des dépôts des banques
aujourd'hui détenus par d'autres
établissements bancaires elle est
extrêmement minime elle est je pense
inférieure à 5% en tout cas vraiment
très faible par rapport aux autres et
donc ces mécanismes de contagion
interbancaire ne sont plus à l'oeuvre
aujourd'hui et je crois que c'est aussi
ce qui explique une une forme de
résilience de résilience du secteur
voilà donc
universalité et capacité à gérer à la
fois une taille et je dirais une un
management une gestion plus exactement
et plus précisément en français dans
notre belle langue de des risques qui
tiennent compte des modèles d'affaires
et des métiers une diversité d'activité
une diversité de clientèle une diversité
géographique avec des clients partout en
France et des clients à l'étranger ce
sont des éléments de sécurité et encore
une fois le rapport de la CPR sur le
marché bancaire français donne une
foultitude de chiffres extrêmement
accessible et intéressant sur l'une des
questions que vous posiez très
précisément sur la gestion de ce risque
de taux je voudrais dire là encore qu'il
y a un élément assez spécifique à la
France peut-être plus fort dans les
banques françaises qu'ailleurs c'est que
le métier de la transformation bancaire
c'est-à-dire au fond être capable de
prêter un moyen long terme à des
entreprises et à des ménages
à partir de ressources qui elles sont de
termes très différenciés il y a des
ressources longues mais il y a aussi des
ressources courtes et très courtes cette
transformation c'est le cœur même du
métier des banques et les banques le
font beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs je dois
dire par exemple pour les crédits
immobiliers ils sont à 4% à taux
variables en France
en moyenne dans les autres pays
européens vous allez avoir 20% et même
bien plus dans d'autres pays alors si je
taquinais nos collègues superviseurs je
dirais qu'effectivement la situation
idéale pour un superviseur bancaire
c'est que ce soit le client qui
subissent les variations de risque mais
bien entendu une bonne partie des règles
sont faites pour que les banques
s'approprient cette gestion interne et
donc pour qu'elle couvre leur risque au
fur et à mesure je crois que c'était
l'une de vos questions et donc c'est
couvertures de risque elles sont prises
au fur et à mesure et elles sont prises
non seulement par le biais d'opérations
pour couvrir ce risque au fur et à
mesure mais également elles sont prises
en coups c'est-à-dire que le coût d'un
crédit il vient également de cette
couverture de risque ce qui fait que
progressivement ça veut dire que quand
les taux augmentent et bien tout
simplement ce coût a été absorbé
initialement par la manière dont vous
avez couvert vos risques voilà donc
c'est ce que je voulais dire c'est que
ce métier de transformation il ne
s'exerce pas au hasard ou en fonction
des fluctuations de métier il s'exerce
de façon structurée au fur et à mesure
que les prêts sont accordés renouvelés
et que les dépôts arrivent
pour en venir au à votre point sur la
réglementation alors la règlementation
européenne tout comme l'été la
réglementation française quand c'était
nationale c'est un atout pour la
solidité d'un système c'est à dire que
on évite alors là encore je vais
utiliser un terme mais je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il existe en français le terme de
dumping le dumping réglementaire c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
négatif et qui a pu poser beaucoup de
difficultés et donc dans beaucoup de
secteurs d'activité aujourd'hui on peut
faire une activité similaire à celle des
banques sans être soumis à la même
réglementation on ne fait pas exactement
la même chose mais on fait une bonne
partie de choses ou alors on peut
exercer le même métier mais tout
simplement le faire dans un autre pays
avec des règles différentes moins 10 ans
bon et s'agissant de l'Union européenne
les banques françaises effectivement ont
été extrêmement critiques sur la
proportionnalité sur l'utilisation de la
proportionnalité pour exempter un
certain nombre de banques et par
ailleurs nous souhaitons également que
cette réglementation correspondent à la
réalité du fonctionnement des banques
européennes je reprends mon exemple tout
à l'heure sur
[Musique]
bancaire européenne et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des écarts très
importants entre les États-Unis et
l'Europe et que effectivement cette
norme internationale qui pour
schématiser très largement pour
schématiser on pourrait passer des
heures à l'expliquer mais pour
schématiser elle est faite pour un
modèle globalement anglo-saxon malgré
tous les efforts qu'on fait les
négociateurs européens et au fond quand
elle s'applique effectivement il faut
quand même que ça couvre vraiment le
risque européen donc la proportionnalité
l'adaptation à nos risques c'est un
élément qui je pense est important j'en
viens à la question de la de la
résolution et des nouvelles règles qui
ont été proposées par la Commission
européenne qui en fait était travaillée
depuis très longtemps qui ont connu
divers aléas et qui ont été présentés
dans un calendrier
que nous considérons je dirais
absolument non urgent pour nous l'agenda
réglementaire européen aujourd'hui il
est déjà bien remplie il faut aller au
terme de ce qui est prévu et surtout il
faut demander à nos homologues
internationaux de faire la même chose
parce que si vous voulez bien appliquer
chez nous sans que ce soit fait ailleurs
au fond à la fin on subit la contagion
de rumeurs alors qu'en réalité nos
règles sont très différents donc ça
c'est vraiment un problème et donc
allons au bout de l'agenda existant et
poussons nos homologues américains à le
faire et en revanche sur
ces fameuses règles bancaires
européennes nous avons Dassé nombreux
problèmes et notamment le fait que ces
règles de résolution elles conduiraient
en réalité les banques petites et
moyennes en fait à renforcer
leur recours aux instruments de contrôle
sans avoir les règles de précaution les
règles préventives au préalable et donc
pour nous c'est exactement le contraire
de ce qu'il faut faire ce texte peut
comporter d'autres éléments utiles pour
clarifier le mode de fonctionnement du
fond de résolution etc mais je dirais
par rapport au fait qu'il laisse au fond
entrer en zone sécurisée et bénéficier
de fonds qui ont été je le rappelle
constitués à 34% par des clients
français ce sont des dizaines de
milliards d'euros que les clients
français ont payé pour la sécurité des
banques européennes dans leur ensemble
et bien s'il s'agit de laisser des
banques moins contrôlées en Europe en
bénéficier du simple fait de leur taille
alors là c'est un vrai problème voilà
donc je résume notre position par ce
point merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs pour votre
attention merci Madame fatigue toujours
très précise madame attig
sur vos positions
donc je m'adresse enfin Madame
laurentialome donc vous portez regard
critique on va dire sur les
réglementations bancaires en vigueur
donc on va vous dire pourquoi et puis
même chose
que pensez-vous de direz-vous des crises
récentes pour pour l'avenir et je vous
indique également que après les
questions de nos collègues pour répondre
en premier je vous préviens et dans
autrement dit dans l'ordre inverse voilà
et pour que vous y prépariez madame je
tiens comme les autres auditionnés à
vous remercier vivement pour cette
audition parce que je pense que le sujet
est vraiment fondamental donc je
voudrais commencer par un petit
flashback
les premières victimes de la crise
financière de 2007-2008 ont été
allemandes avec IKEA B britannique avec
Norton rock et ensuite la crise est
venue par vague on a eu beer stills à
partir de mars 2008
qui a été racheté en moins d'une semaine
la crise de liquidité l'a emporté
rachetée par JP Morgan chaise et ensuite
on a eu tout le monde se souvient du on
a tous l'âge de se souvenir en tout cas
du chaos financier qui a suivi la
faillite de l'éman et si on regarde les
déclarations des autorités publiques des
régulateurs des superviseurs au début de
la crise les déclarations étaient très
rassurantes ce qui est normal ce qui est
normal les régulateurs n'ont absolument
pas à mettre le feu aux poudres je suis
d'accord mais bon donc ça veut dire que
je trouve qu'il est parfaitement
légitime que cette audition ait lieu et
il est parfaitement légitime de se poser
la question est-ce que dans quelques
années est-ce que dans quelques années
on considérera que les faillits de SVB
silverget first Republic crédit le
rachat de crédit Suisse auront été le
début d'une vague de faillite à
répétition c'est une question légitime
alors
bien sûr les comment dire les racines
des difficultés les racines des
difficultés des banques régionales
américaines et de crédits suisses sont
très différents ce qui est important
c'est que dans les deux cas la
conséquence a été une fuite très massive
et très rapide beaucoup plus rapide que
ce n'est pas le cas avant des dépôts
nécessitant l'intervention des autorités
publiques des apports massifs de
liquidité de la part des banques
centrales et des deux côtés de
l'Atlantique malgré les engagements des
gouvernements à dire plus jamais les
fonds des contribuables ne seront
engagés et plus jamais les contribuables
n'auront à payer pour les dérives
bancaires malgré le fait qu'on est
réformé nos systèmes de résolution qu'on
est introduit du being dedans et bien
malgré cela les fonds publics ont été
engagés et massivement je voudrais dire
que d'ailleurs que depuis 2015 il y a eu
6 failles bancaires en Europe et sur ces
6 failles bancaires il y en a qu'une qui
a respecté les règles ces banques au
popular les cinq autres ont nécessité
l'engagement de fonds publics en dépit
des règles que nous nous sommes
collectivement donnés et ce fut
notamment le cas pour monter des
hépatites et Sienna systémique au niveau
italien il est clair aujourd'hui que la
rapidité l'ampleur des réactions à la
fois des banques centrales des Trésor
Public concernés dudic c'est l'assurance
des poids américaines témoignent en
dépli des déclarations très rassurantes
normales habituelles d'une inquiétude
nécessairement d'une inquiétude qui
prévaut des deux côtés de l'Atlantique
c'est faillites sont en effet très
instructive pour éclairer les risques
qui pèsent sur les bilans bancaires
alors d'abord elle confirme quelque
chose qu'on sait bien qui a été couronné
par le dernier prix Nobel c'est que les
banques elles sont très vulnérables au
risque de liquidité du fait de leur
structure de bilan et du déséquilibre de
maturité entre l'actif et le passif ce
que les épisodes récents nous apprennent
c'est que cette vulnérabilité elle est
décuplée à l'ère du numérique
c'est comment dire c'est cette
vulnérabilité est décuplée à l'air du
numérique dans tous les cas récents la
crise et la faillite est venue d'une
crise de liquidité pas d'une crise de
dégradation de la qualité de l'actif
là je voudrais noter que Crédit Suisse
puisque le cas européen et bien crédit
Suède Crédit Suisse dépassait de
beaucoup les deux ratios clés de bal 3
ça il faut l'avoir en tête c'est à dire
que le Common écouter one et le LCR
Crédit Suisse Cochet parfaitement les
cases il avait un comment dire Crédit
Suisse avait un ratio
de solvabilité ça le ratio cœur de
comment écouter one de 14,1% la limite
européenne est autour de
10,6%. et je voudrais dire que certaines
de nos banques systémiques BNP Paribas
et Société Générale ont un ratio qui est
inférieur au ratio de crédit Suisse
Crédit Suisse respectait également son
ratio de liquidité il était très
supérieur le
lcrio très supérieure à 100% et il était
précisément à 144%. je voudrais dire que
deux de nos banques systémiques toujours
Société Générale et BNP Paribas ont un
ratio de liquidité elle sert inférieure
je ne cherche pas du tout là à vous dire
attention c'est de banques sont dans la
situation de c'est pas du tout ce que je
cherche à dire je veux juste te dire que
ça donne un faux sentiment de sécurité
de simplement regarder les ratios de
balle 3 et se dire c'est bon on est
tranquille on est protégé non pas du
tout les c'est un très bon outil dans la
dans la boîte et outils du régulateur
les accords de mal3 sont fondamentaux le
problème c'est que il n'offre pas du
tout une garantie suffisante au
contribuable on a bien vu
et ni à l'économie dans son ancien et
surtout ils peuvent induire un faux
sentiment de sécurité un faux sentiment
de sécurité et comment dire le sentiment
que l'ALEA moral est maîtrisée alors
qu'en réalité il n'est pas du tout
particulièrement dans les systèmes où on
a des banques c'est pour ça que là de ce
point de vue je ne vous rejoindrai pas
je ne pense pas que le fait qu'on ait
autant de banksystémiques contenu de
leur taille contenu relatives à la
taille du Pipe français soit
nécessairement une bonne chose mais bon
ça ça on pourra y revenir bon donc si
vous voulez je pense qu'il faudrait
davantage se concentrer sur le ratio de
levier simple c'est à dire non pondéré
par les risques et pourquoi ben parce
qu'il y a plein d'autres tuiles
empiriques aux États-Unis et en Europe
qui montrent que c'est un bien meilleur
prédicteur de Fight bancaires et si on
regarde le ratio de levier simple la
situation des banques notamment
françaises et un petit peu moins comment
dire un petit peu moins favorable disons
qu'une baisse de l'ordre de 5 6% selon
les banques de la valeur de leurs actifs
d'un gros accident sur le orbylan sur
les dérivés qui entraînerait des pertes
de ce niveau et bien ça signifie que ça
mangerait tout leur capital enfin je
veux dire un moment il faut dire les
choses également donc ça veut dire que
non seulement les ratios de balle 3 ne
nous protège pas véritablement même
s'ils sont très utiles
mais les la réforme du prince des
principes de résolution ne nous protège
pas non plus nous l'avons vu également
mais en plus de ça la transposition de
balles 3 en Europe n'est toujours pas
finalisée n'est toujours pas finalisé et
les instances européennes soutiennent
des règles prudentielles qui sont en
deçà en réalité des exigences de
maltroit et ce faisant les institutions
européennes et bien
ignorent les alertes à ce sujet des
principaux superviseurs bancaires qu'il
s'agisse d'Andrea henrien le président
du conseil de surveillance de la BCE
qu'il s'agisse de Louise des gwendos le
vice-président de la BCE qu'il s'agisse
de José Manuel campa le président de
l'Autorité bancaire européenne 3 ont
alerté sur et ont mis en garde sur le
fait que la non pleine application de
balles 3 dans l'Union européenne
posez un risque majeur en fait de
non-conformité qui porterait atteinte à
la confiance qu'on peut avoir dans dans
nos banques
donc si vous voulez je pense qu'il faut
absolument aller comment dire pleinement
appliquer les accords de balle 3
actuellement la Commission européenne
prévoit alors que déjà la pleine
application était prévue pour 2028 la
Commission européenne prévoit de donner
encore un délai supplémentaire pour
l'application de certaines dispositions
notamment ce qu'on appelle le plancher
de fonds propres or le plancher de fonds
propres est absolument indispensable
pour la stabilité bancaire et qui plus
est puisqu'on a parlé des petites et des
grandes banques le plancher de fonds
propres est essentiel pour une
concurrence éthique équitable entre les
petites et les grandes banques pourquoi
et bien parce que les études académiques
montrent également qu'il n'y a que les
manque qui sont capables par
l'utilisation des approches les plus
avancées de leur modèle interne de
minimiser enfin en tout cas de réduire
la valeur de leur actif pondéré par les
rides c'est-à-dire du dénominateur du
ratio de capital chose comme pas faire
les plus petites banques donc en plus il
y a comment dire une entrave à une
concurrence qui soit équitable entre les
différentes banques et donc je pense que
ce - 10 ans
prudentiel risque de conduire et ça
serait à juste titre le fait de que le
comité de balle considère que les règles
de l'Union européenne serait non
conforme et d'ailleurs l'Autorité
bancaire européenne la souligner et ça
ça aurait un impact considérable sur la
confiance dans nos banques on l'a vu
avec la faille des banques régionales
avec Crédit Suisse la confiance et le
principal actif d'une certaine manière
d'une banque je veux dire on peut avoir
toutes les règles qu'on veut si la
confiance disparaît et s'il est dépôt
disparaissent et ça peut se faire en un
clic maintenant donc c'est vraiment un
enjeu je pense très très important et
donc compte tenu de du contexte
macroéconomique actuel du contexte de
remontée des taux du contexte
d'instabilité bancaire je pense que
c'est délai dans la pleine application
des accords de balles sont très
dommagesables sont très dommages à pour
la stabilité bancaire pour la protection
des contribuables et pour la concurrence
équitable entre les banques donc ceci
étant deux mots sur enfin vraiment très
rapidement sur les risques qui me
semblent aujourd'hui très important dans
les bilans bancaires donc on l'a vu
d'abord le risque de liquidité donc le
risque de liquidité mais il faut combien
comprendre que ce risque qui est
constitutif de la banque une banque
c'est fait pour avoir des ressources à
court terme et de prêter à long terme
mais ce risque est exacerbé dans un
contexte de remontée de remontée des
taux d'intérêt particulièrement quand on
parle de taux très bas parce que la
sensible techniquement la sensibilité du
cours des obligations est plus forte
quand les quand les remontées se font à
tout bas peu importe et
c'est également très important parce que
les banques se sont habituées en fait
avec les politiques monétaires
monétaires non conventionnelles d'une
certaine manière à déléguer la gestion
de la liquidité à la Banque centrale
européenne si on a beaucoup moins
d'engagements interbancaires bah c'est
largement parce que les banques
centrales se sont mis ce sont
substituées au marché interbancaire
soyons clairs c'est quand même très
largement à ça et donc du coup ben voilà
la gestion de la liquidité est peut-être
pas tout à fait aussi bien fait que ça
ne aurait pu l'être et puis il me semble
qu'il faut absolument recalibrer en fait
les ratios de liquidité notamment à
l'air des paniques des paniques
bancaires numériques et c'est un terme
qui avait été qui avait été popularisé
par le président de la bundesbanque
c'est-à-dire les panique bancaires
numériques c'est-à-dire que à l'ère du
numérique aujourd'hui est la circulation
de l'information même des fausses
informations et la vitesse à laquelle
les dépôts peuvent fuir et sans commune
mesure donc bon et donc la manière dont
est calibré le LCR je pense nous ne
correspond plus à la réalité
aujourd'hui on pourra y revenir un autre
risque majeur qui a été évoqué par
par l'Autorité bancaire européenne c'est
dans un contexte de durcissement
monétaire une dégradation de la qualité
de l'actif bancaire donc avec une montée
des failles d'entreprise et des créances
douteuses à ça on peut s'y attendre je
rappellerai quand même quand Mars 2023
le Haut Conseil de stabilité financière
à inciter les banques à être très
vigilante quant à leur exposition sur
les entreprises les plus endettées je
rappellerai que la France se caractérise
par un très fort niveau d'endettement
privé des ménages mais surtout des
sociétés non financières très supérieure
à celui de la plupart de nos collègues
de nos partenaires européens le dernier
risque qui n'a pas du tout été évoqué
lors de cette table ronde et qui me
semble vraiment majeure et qui est
sous-évalué je pense et par les acteurs
bancaires et par et par disons le paquet
bancaire de l'Union européenne concerne
l'exposition au risque financier
d'origine climatique
en particulier le risque de transition
dans la proposition actuelle du
comment dire du paquet bancaire de
l'Union européenne dans la proposition
non pas dans l'approvision actuelle de
règlement sur la table des collèges
latéraux européens il y a pas de
véritable prise en compte à la hauteur
du problème de cette question des
risques financiers adossés aux fossiles
l'ONG final Swatch et pour toute
transparence je suis membre qualifiée de
ONG Finance Watch donc je dis les choses
voilà l'ONG final Swatch a produit un
rapport en octobre 2022 montrant que les
60 plus grandes banques du monde parmi
lesquelles les 22 plus grandes banques
de l'Union européenne et donc parmi
lesquels nos six plus grandes banques
françaises détiennent 1350 milliards de
dollars d'actifs fossiles dans leur
bilan c'est à dire plus que la somme des
actifs à risque au moment du début de la
crise des subprimes
si on croit qu'on va faire et moi je
veux le croire une transition vers une
économie bas carbone si la volonté
politique de faire cette transition bas
carbone se concrétise nombre de ses
actifs adossés aux fossiles vont
s'échouer c'est à dire vont fortement se
dévaloriser pourquoi et bien parce que
ces actifs vont être abandonnés ils vont
cesser d'être exploités avant la fin de
leur durée de vie et avant amortissement
d'où le qualificatif d'actifs échoué
pour protéger les banques contre les
pertes massives qui vont en résulter qui
pourront compromettre leur solvabilité
qui pourront affecter la confiance des
déposants et on a vu à quel point la
question de la confiance était posant
était centrale et pouvait conduire à une
faillite bancaire je pense qu'il faut
impérativement intégrer ces risques dans
le ratio de capital réglementaire
financourt a une proposition qui est
d'appliquer un coefficient de
pondération des risques sectoriels de
de 150% aux expositions des banques à
des actifs fossiles dans une approche
assez similaire dans un article que j'ai
publié avec Gaëtan le coang dans
international
on a proposé un ratio de levier
sectorielle c'est-à-dire qui s'applique
créer aux expositions sur le secteur de
la protection de la prospection et de
l'exploitation des énergies fossiles qui
évidemment sera un niveau qui mord plus
que le ratio de levier non sectoriel
actuellement inclus dans les accords de
balle donc voilà je vous remercie de
votre attention et je pense avoir
respecté les temps
merci Madame
et merci à tous les quatre pour ce
tableau global de la situation et vous
répondrez les uns et les autres
éventuellement à certaines affirmations
monsieur alors j'ai peut-être
mais je reste assez simple j'ai toujours
l'impression que de toute façon la
banque par nature c'est un métier à
risque d'une certaine façon
transformée du court terme à long terme
quand ça se retourne si on vous demande
l'aider de le remboursement des dépôts à
la minute il y a une façon de faire qui
est très simple en transforme pas on
stock et on attend qu'on vous demande et
on fait rien bon donc si vous voulez dès
l'instant où on fait cette
transformation on crée le risque de
façon donc la question est toujours une
question de niveau d'acceptabilité et de
sécurisation et pour tout dire vous avez
dit le mot de confiance dans le système
voilà c'est quand même toujours le mot
clé au-delà de toutes les techniques que
l'on peut mettre en œuvre monsieur le
rapporteur général
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames et messieurs
habituellement c'est un peu l'effet
inverse donc
c'est une
un sujet intéressant on a voulu à la
fois écouter
et auditionner celles et ceux qui sont
là pour
je sais pas si elle le serait nous
rassurer mais en tous les cas garantir
par la supervision les modalités de
contrôle et puis amener également à
travers madame Scialom des
interpellations enfin faire j'ai vu que
ça fonctionne d'ailleurs j'ai bien
entendu
ça réagit dans dans notre commission moi
je vais aborder plusieurs questions
la première qui concerne la Banque
centrale européenne dans les taux
directeurs en grandement évolué ça
continue aujourd'hui
quel finalement quel impact cette
nouvelle hausse parce que c'est pas la
première
peut-elle avoir sur le bilan des banques
et pensez-vous d'ailleurs qui qu'il
existe un seuil limite à partir duquel
le niveau des taux serait susceptible de
peser sur les bilans des banques pour
être absorbables la question du seuil
limite j'ai bien compris la la
couverture les sécurités enfin elles
existait déjà quand les sécurités
sautées si je fais un raccourcir en 2008
et puisque je parle de 2008 selon vous
quelles sont les
les qu'est-ce qui distingue les
événements bancaires récents de 2008 je
vais un peu plus loin
j'observe qu'il y a toujours des
systèmes de
titrisation et on se souvient qu'on
avait
mis ça à jour voire découvert en 2008 je
rappelle que c'est ce qui permet aussi
de sortir de leur bilan certains risques
éventuellement de les revendre donc
est-ce que est-ce qu'on est cette fois
soit à l'abri soit est-ce qu'on n'y est
pas justement et ce qui reste
préoccupant
autre question est-ce que par rapport à
ce qui s'est passé en Suisse alors je
crois que tout le monde est assez
d'accord pour dire qu'il y a des
modalités qui étaient beaucoup trop
lâches ça j'ai bien entendu et en tous
les cas c'est une anime mais il y a le
sujet à la fois de des règles liées à
l'honorabilité des dirigeants et au
contrôle des risques
pensez-vous donc que nous soyons mieux
protégés qu'en Suisse
un aspect qui concerne les
déposants dans la faillite de la Silicon
Valley banque les dépôts étaient
garantis à hauteur de 250 000 dollars
alors même que le système libéral ne
garantissait pas or en ce qui nous
concerne en Europe les garanties les
dépôts sont garantis à hauteur de
100.000 euros est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est suffisant
et que
ça peut nous éviter un bank run comme
c'était évoqué dans le cas des
États-Unis
et puis je poserai une question qui à
mon avis concerne plus
les personnes situées à ma droite
j'ai bien évoqué les les
sujets de régulation et de supervision
de risque de taux pourquoi ce dispositif
n'est-il pas appliqué selon les mêmes
modalités me semble-t-il dans le cas des
compagnies d'assurance puisque le risque
de taux obéissent à la même logique
et puis je vais aller un peu plus loin
je le dis parce que je veux que le
message soit entendu sur le besoin me
semble-t-il de d'un peu de liberté et de
concurrence maîtrisée je le dis parce
que ça peut avoir des conséquences et
sur les garanties et sur un jour la
positivité de transférabilité des
contrats d'assurance ce qui permettrait
de garantir les produits avec qui sont
placés par les déposants sur des durées
longues et comme ça financier économie
on est là plutôt pour la financer
utilement non pas pour provoquer des
ruptures
merci Monsieur Potter général
donc je vais donner la parole à Michel
Canevet puis Sylvie vermillier merci
monsieur le Président je voudrais voir
également remercier les intervenants
pour leurs éclairages alors à Madame
silhomme et Madame attique je voulais
leur demander si le fait que l'on est
dans les principales 10% des principales
banques
mondial international en France est-ce
que c'était un problème pour le
dynamisme le déconvenue française est-ce
qu'il y a pas plus de place dans notre
pays pour des banques de plus petites
tailles c'était une première question et
une deuxième question qui
portait sur l'amplification des ratios
de prudence socialité est-ce que tout
ceci n'est pas finalement néfaste au
développement de de l'économie je veux
dire par là qu'à force de pouvoir
je dirais circonscrire l'action et
d'imposer un certain nombre de règles
prudentielles finalement est-ce qu'on
n'arrive pas à rendre le secteur
économique plus atone puisque les
banques sont plus frileuses à intervenir
même si on voit qu'elle dégage des
résultats tout à fait confortables et ce
matin en évoquait le premier trimestre
de candidat agricole qui est encore
meilleur que celui de l'année dernière
qui était déjà d'excès qui était déjà
excellent et puis à Monsieur Michaud je
voulais lui demander compte tenu de la
situation de l'endettement que Madame
Chalam a qualifié de d'élever en France
l'endettement notamment des ménages mais
malgré cela nous avons un vrai problème
d'accès
au logement on a des difficultés à
pouvoir produire des logements tels
qu'ils le faudrait aujourd'hui est-ce
que ceci tient à mon sens a des règles
prudentielles qui ont été mises en
oeuvre par le Conseil de la stabilité
financière qui sont extrêmement
draconiennes notamment les taux
d'endettement est-ce que ça se passe de
la même manière dans les autres pays
européens est-ce qu'il y a des règles
prudentielles pour l'accès des ménages
à l'immobilier notamment qui sont aussi
drastiques que dans notre pays
merci Michel Sylvie vermeiller puis
Jérôme bachel merci monsieur le
Président ma question complète l'une des
questions de Michel Canevet c'est sur le
niveau de réglementation madame attique
vous avez fait état de la difficulté de
l'application de toutes les normes de
balle 3 de toutes les exigences et le
poids de cette réglementation face à la
concurrence internationale notamment en
matière de crédit immobilier des taux
variables cette application et donc on
comprend cette difficulté ensuite pour
les banques françaises notamment à
supporter et à lutter dans face à ces
enjeux de concurrence
néanmoins vous avez dit que cette
réglementation était un atout pour la
solidité de nos banques donc moi ma
question c'est quel est où est la marge
de manœuvre quelle serait la meilleure
optimisation puisque d'autres parts
quand vous avez évoqué la question du
ratio de liquidité vous êtes heureuse
vous avez dit que le ratio de liquidité
de nos banques était de 15% là où la
moyenne était de neuf donc finalement on
a un ratio liquidité dans les bacs
françaises qui qui est plus élevé
qu'ailleurs et pour autant la
réglementation vous semble excessive
donc
vous voyez où je vais en venir il me
semble que même si la réglementation est
ce qu'elle est les banques françaises
sont particulièrement prudentes en ayant
un taux de liquidité élevé donc
quelque part vous assurez évidemment et
c'est heureux pour nous
une véritable prudence mais est-ce que
pourquoi est-ce que vous assureriez 15%
de de taux de liquidité si quelque part
ça limite votre puissance en matière de
concurrence voilà ma question où est la
marge de manœuvre merci
merci Sylvie Jérôme Bachar puis Eric
Bocquet
merci monsieur le Président tout d'abord
un propos liminaire effectivement
m'étonner que la professeur vous nous
reconnaissiez une légitimité j'en suis
bien heureux mais permettez-moi aussi de
reconnaître la vôtre donc mais c'est
bien le Parlement qui est légitime je
crois donc nos questions sont toujours
légitimes
ce propos est en fait
moi je me réjouis d'abord que le système
bancaire français soit dans les premiers
Européens et premiers mondiaux on est
toujours à se comparer avec nos amis
allemands dont on est au flat
l'industrie il est quand même assez
heureux qu'en France on puisse aussi
avoir quelque chose qui fait un peu
référence dans le monde et donc je sais
bien que beaucoup avaient préféré qu'on
soit les derniers partout mais moi je
préfère qu'on ait un système bancaire
résilient
reconnu comme tel même si je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous se limiter à
deux ratios c'est un peu court mais
c'est bien pour cela que je crois la CPR
fait un petit peu autre chose que ces
deux ratios lors de ces examens
témoins comme présidente de comité
d'audité des risques un grand
établissement financier de savoir que
c'est un peu plus compliqué que cela
moi j'ai un sujet sur la pondération des
d'un certain nombre de systèmes
financier assez classique et assez
historique sur nos banques pour pouvoir
développer l'économie comme ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure très justement
par Michel Calvet par exemple les sujets
de crédit Lombard qui sont donc aussi
vieux que la Lombardie a inventé à peu
près la banque et bien c'est sujet là
aujourd'hui sont très pénalisants par
rapport à des crédits classiques et on
peut se demander parfois pourquoi et ça
permettrait sans doute à un certain
nombre d'établissements de pouvoir se
financer
deuxième sujet ma crainte principale
n'est peut-être pas forcément dans le
système bancaire plutôt que dans et ça a
été très bien évoqué par le taux
d'endettement général de la France
endettement public
endettement des entreprises et le
gouverneur de la Banque de France nous
la rappelle quasiment systématiquement
et endettement des ménages la France est
le seul pays dont l'endettement sur ces
trois aspects n'a cessé de progresser et
c'est peut-être là plus le risque majeur
à un moment où effectivement on a donc
une abondance de dette y compris de
dettes publiques qui n'est plus rachetée
par la Banque centrale européenne et
donc on peut avoir un sujet de
surabondance et d'évaluation notamment
de l'actif et des prix de l'endettement
donc moi c'est inquiétude est peut-être
plus là je m'adresse aux côtés
régulateur
enfin la France à cette spécificité
d'être
un bon assureur
et c'est là sans doute une de ses forces
mais c'est aussi une de ces faiblesses
parce que la banque et l'assurance ne
sont pas régulées de la même façon si
elles sont régulées toutes les deux
certes elles sont pas régulées de la
même façon et notamment en termes de
normes comptables qui peut avoir des
gros impacts suivant que vous soyez un
bon assureur ou un assureur banque
parce qu'il est faits 17 n'a pas
forcément le même impact suivant la
norme et moi ce qui m'inquiète je vous
le dis c'est les petites banques aussi
mais encore plus le secteur dont le
secteur non régulé car j'ai envie de
dire c'est ce dont on n'a pas parlé la
banque elle est régulée alors si je dis
pas qu'il y a pas des faillites il y a
nid to be to fait small is beautiful
dans aucun cas sur la banque il faut
réguler partout mais il y a tout le
secteur non régulé et moi c'est plus
cela qui m'inquiète ceux qui titrise
autant comme autant comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure le rapporteur général et sur
lesquels on ne sait pas ce qui se passe
et c'est là où il y a des fonds majeurs
des fonds de fonds des fontitrisés et
recoupées dans tous les sens et ma
crainte est vraiment là qu'est-ce que le
régulateur compte faire sur ce secteur
là qui est parfois très performant
mais pour le celui qui a la chance
d'avoir de l'argent là-dedans mais qui
est surtout pour moi la vraie grande
source de risque qui est en dessous de
la
merci Jérôme
Eric Bocquet puis Vincent Segoin oui
merci monsieur le Président moi je me
félicite de la tenue de cette table
ronde de pluraliste on a besoin dans nos
réflexions de tous ces avis et non pas
seulement la langue officielle entre
guillemets de la supervision de
l'industrie financière donc je suis
satisfait que nous puissions entendre
d'autres tons d'autres propos sur ce
sujet
madame Masset pour la CPA vous avez dit
un moment que les turbulences actuels ne
remettaient pas en question les règles
qui avaient été mises en oeuvre mais
simplement donc est-ce qu'elles ont été
mises en oeuvre d'abord partiellement ou
de manière incomplète est-ce que vous
pourriez préciser ce point parce que
j'avais le sentiment que après la crise
de 2008 qui a tout qui a tout chamboulé
l'économie mondiale je me souviens de ce
G20 à Londres en 2009 où les 20 chefs
d'État avaient pris normalement des
mesures pour empêcher qu'une telle des
crise survienne à nouveau et ça a été
rappelé par un madame Scialom il y a
quand même de nombreuses répliques
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pensez j'ai lu un
articleurément dans l'excellent journal
des secours qui est ma bible mon livre
de chevet comme vous le savez et
Monsieur monsieur vitori monsieur
vittory éditorialiste évoquait l'idée
d'aller jusqu'à la mise en cause de la
responsabilité personnelle des banquiers
en cas de crise parce que bon il y a
toujours l'allée à moral l'État
intervient la résa fédérale américaine
2025 milliards sur la table par rapport
à la Silicon Valley banque pour éteindre
l'incendie très vite parce qu'il y a des
risques systémiques est-ce que ça
pourrait aller c'est monsieur vitori qui
dit ça je le cite
jusqu'à la mise en cause personnelle de
la responsabilité des banquiers qui ont
eu des pratiques un peu litigieuses
voire plus voilà voilà ce qu'il était
quel était ma question merci
ta question plutôt tes questions me
semble-t-il alors Vincent Segoin puis
Emmanuel Capu
oui merci Monsieur Président on voit
bien un développement des banques avec
la régulation tel que vous l'avez décrit
qui est de plus en plus draconienne on
assiste à des fusions de plus en plus de
banques qui deviennent de plus en plus
grosses
ma question c'est est-ce que la taille
de la banque permet une meilleure
résistance
quelle est votre avis là-dessus en
parallèle se développe des banques
numériques internationales qui gère des
crypto monnaie qui sont
qui passe sous contrôle un peu de tout
ma question c'est
quels sont avec la hausse des taux les
effets possibles sur ces banques et les
conséquences sur nos banques en France
qui investissent de plus en plus actifs
merci Vincent Emmanuel Capu
merci monsieur le Président moi j'avais
deux questions la première sur la
finance verte et la deuxième sur les
crypto monnaie qui vient d'être un tout
petit peu abordé sur la finance verte
madame sialom l'avait également abordé
on voit bien que l'inflation découle
très majoritairement de la crise
énergétique
on a aussi ça a été abordé
le dérèglement climatique que nous
connaissons donc on a une modification
des investissements dans les différents
types d'énergie j'ai bien entendu donc
le positionnement madame qui est de dire
que le il y a un vrai risque sur les
énergies fossiles et dans
l'investissement dans les énergies
fossiles donc j'ai une deuxième question
est-ce que c'est est-ce que le risque
existe aussi sur l'investissement
important que nous avons à faire dans
les énergies nucléaires et plus
globalement je voudrais savoir si les
autres intervenants partagent
l'inquiétude de Madame le professeur
madame la professeur
sur sur ces investissements dans les
énergies fossiles
la deuxième question sur les crypto
monnaie que vient d'évoquer un petit peu
Vincent Segoin c'est malgré la
dépréciation des actifs on l'a vu
la crise qui a touché certains acteurs
des crypto monnaie est-ce qu'on n'est
pas sur une tendance de fond quand même
d'investissement dans ces deux
développements de ces crypto monnaie et
donc est-ce que ça ne risque pas de
déstabiliser le secteur bancaire et
est-ce que ça n'induit pas des risques
sur les bilans bancaires dans tous les
cas sur le modèle économique du secteur
bancaire merci beaucoup
merci Emmanuel pour ma part j'aurais
peut-être également une question
d'abord à partir d'un élément qui
m'avait fait beaucoup rire peut-être à
tort
qui était un mot responsable
gouvernemental
interrogé
immédiatement après la diffusion de la
question sur la Silicon Valley banque
qui répondait il n'y a pas de risque
puisque aucune de nos banques ne
travaille avec Silicon Valley banque
j'en suis resté pour tout dire
interloqué je sais bien qu'on peut tout
dire à la population y compris quand on
veut rassurer dire bon voilà c'est une
façon de rassurer sans doute mais à
force de vouloir toujours avoir un
discours rassurant on finit par plus
être crédible d'une certaine façon
et quand même il pensait qu'aujourd'hui
les choses
font que ne font pas qu'une banque
quelle qu'elle soit de l'instant ou est
importante évidemment significative mais
c'est pas une des plus grandes n'est pas
des répercussions sur les autres banques
de son pays et donc de ce fait sur
l'ensemble des banques du monde
ne pas ne pas s'exprimer comme ça et en
disant après bon c'est quand même quand
on est limité que sais-je la Fed a fait
ce qu'elle avait à faire peu importe
enfin il y a des moments où il faut
arrêter quoi bon les choses sont en fait
toujours et aujourd'hui dans le secteur
bancaire et secteur financier elles sont
à l'échelle mondiale c'est comme ça et
donc on peut faire des réglementations
françaises c'est chouette on peut faire
des réglementations européennes c'est
souhaitable on peut essayer de les
mettre en œuvre c'est encore mieux c'est
pas toujours ça va pas toujours la
vitesse de la lumière mais en tout cas
si derrière on a des banques qui ne sont
pas contrôlées dans d'autres pays ça
fait les mêmes dégâts
que si voilà qu'on soit nous contrôlé ou
pas alors c'est toujours mieux
moralement que ce soit pas nos banques
qui soient à l'origine du problème je
conçois mais franchement en tant que
citoyen plaçant mon argent à la banque
sans rien ne me rassure dans ce qui est
dit encore quoi et moi tant qu'il y a
pas tant qu'on dit les américains ils
plus voilà
comment dire traiter leur banque
différemment mettre des seuils
différents etc puis ensuite ils se
rendent compte qu'il y a un problème
sans compte que des preuves mais quelle
mesure ils vont prendre et est-ce qu'on
n'est pas capable quand même dans cette
fonction dans ces métiers qui sont des
métiers
fondamentaux pour l'économie mondiale
bon
voilà est-ce qu'on peut pas quand même
arriver un jour au moins au niveau des
grands pays qui ont les plus grands de
banque résultats à se mettre d'accord
sur les principes les principes solides
voilà moi je veux je pense encore qu'il
y a trop de risques dans le monde je
veux dire globalement
et puis ça pose aussi les problèmes
indiqués la Fédération des banques que
évidemment c'est des espèces de
concurrence déloyale
oui bien sûr si toutes les banques ne
sont pas subjectives alors avec des
échelles qu'on peut éventuellement
imaginer encore que mais ne sont pas
susgés ou même règle on comprend bien et
c'est quand même extraordinaire d'être à
la fois
essayer d'être le bon élève dans
certains pays et puis quand même prendre
la vague comme les autres finalement
tout en ayant payé pour essayer d'éviter
la vague bon il y a quelque chose
là-dedans de voilà c'est pour ça que moi
j'arrive pas
je le dis au régulateur
j'arrive pas à être totalement rassuré
par le discours et et par le discours
d'autorité qui consiste à dire nous
c'est beaucoup mieux qu'ailleurs oui
sans doute c'est beaucoup mieux
qu'ailleurs mais on sait pas le sujet le
sujet c'est qu'il faut que ça soit
partout pareil voilà enfin
en tout cas que le système tient à
l'échelle du système c'est à dire de la
terre voilà
c'est comme ça enfin c'est mon point de
vue donc si vous pouviez dans vos dans
vos commentaires exposer sinon en
reprenant l'ensemble des questions de
nos collègues évidemment celles qui vous
paraissent se relever de votre
de votre responsabilité mais en même
temps essayer de me rassurer encore un
peu plus que par des propos d'autorité
disons c'est comme ça on est mieux etc
prière de croix j'aurais
beaucoup mieux si vous pouviez aller un
peu plus loin sur la perspective
internationale de résolution de ces
sujets voilà alors on va démarrer par
Madame sialom alors vous indique là vous
avez le temps qui est diminué par deux
c'est à dire au lieu de 10,5 et comme on
ne dépasse toujours un peu ça sera 7
voilà mais tout compris
TVA comprise
[Musique]
probablement de déclatement d'une bulle
immobilière parce que je pense qu'il y a
eu bu l'Immobilière avec les niveaux
anormalement bas qu'on a eu sur les prix
d'actifs et ça c'est danger du point de
vue des banques crise immobilière c'est
vraiment danger parce que ça va ça veut
dire que c'est la valeur du collatéral
qui va s'effondrer et donc la capacité à
rembourser les prêts et en plus la
valeur de la garantie ça on connaît bien
on connaît bien le mécanisme la valeur
de la baisse de la valeur des actifs
donc voilà donc et on peut quel bon
niveau de taux d'intérêt sincèrement je
suis incapable de le dire mais surtout
on peut s'interroger sur est-ce que
c'est le bon outil pour
lutter contre l'inflation telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui même la BCE
aujourd'hui a souligner que la boucle
c'est pas une boucle prise salaire c'est
une boucle prix profit pour l'instant
essentiellement qui alimente la
dynamique plus comme vous l'avez
souligné des facteurs des composants de
la plus volatils de l'inflation qui pour
l'instant d'ailleurs ont plutôt baissé
et notamment avec le départ la crise
énergétique et les chaînes de valeur
perturber suite à la crise covid etc
donc on peut se poser la question est-ce
que ce sont les bons moyens et
d'ailleurs même certains banquiers
centraux ont fait des annonces là-dessus
notamment l'inflation d'origine
climatique vous l'avez évoqué Isabelle
Schnabel membre du directoire a fait un
superbe discours sur les trois types
d'inflation faut-il fashion et bon bref
et donc une inflation qui est liée à la
transition énergétique et ça c'est pas
une hausse des taux d'intérêt
indifférencier qui y répond ça peut être
par contre des taux très favorables si
on finance la transition écologique etc
voilà quelle distinction entre la crise
de 2008 et la crise actuelle d'abord je
voudrais reprendre le terme très connu
en économie cette fois c'est différent
c'est à dire que on vous dit toujours
que la crise actuelle elle est
différente de la de l'ancienne alors
c'est vrai les sources sont toujours
différentes moi qui ai travaillé un peu
sur l'histoire bancaire et financière
les crises sont toujours d'origine
différentes néanmoins il y a des
dénominateur à toutes les crises
bancaires et financières niveau
d'endettement excessif des acteurs
privés gestion des risques qui est qui
est détendu parce qu'on a eu des
conditions monétaires trop trop laxistes
précédemment
régulation insuffisante la crise des
années 30 est née dans le Shadow parce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le shadow
banking qu'on appelait pas ça et la
tristrisation ça s'appelait pas comme ça
ça existait aussi à l'époque donc voilà
donc
mais toutes les crises ont donc des
dénominateurs communs et moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
plupart des dénominateurs qu'on trouve
dans presque toutes les crises on les a
donc alors c'est vrai que bal 3 amélioré
les choses que les fonds propres sont
beaucoup plus élevés mais on partait de
presque rien faut savoir que quand les
banques européennes sont rentrées dans
la crise si on regarde le ratio de
levier simple c'est à dire pas ratio
composé par les risques parce que là on
avait l'impression que c'est tout allait
bien mais certaines sont rentrés avec 1%
de capital de vrais capte de vrais
capitales je veux dire quand
donc voilà donc c'est bien de dire on
l'a triplé on a quadruplé ouais d'accord
mais triplé au quadriplés pas presque
rien ça fait toujours pas grand chose
quoi enfin j'exagère évidemment mais
c'est pour vous de montrer pour vous
montrer l'idée donc donc un des
problèmes c'est effectivement le shadow
banking on n'a pas utilisé le nom
aujourd'hui mais ça c'est un vrai
problème il est aujourd'hui plus
important qu'il ne l'était avant avant
la crise de 2008
concernant les modalités de résolution
est-ce qu'on est plus protégé qu'en
Suisse donc d'abord je voudrais rappeler
pour l'anecdote
UBS qui s'en sort quand même très très
bien avec cette opération franchement
c'est bingo hein avait lui-même été
renfloué en 2008 donc ça c'est par une
ironie de l'histoire et qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on crée un mastodonte encore plus
grand que que ce qu'on avait on peut se
demander maintenant si à l'échelle de la
Suisse c'est pas toubib tout ça est-ce
que la Suisse peut se permettre d'avoir
une banque aussi grosse que la fusion du
BS est Crédit Suisse donc effectivement
il a été rappeler que les modalités de
résolution étaient vraiment
problématiques puisque ce qu'on avait
décidé collectivement c'était pour des
raisons de limiter l'aléa morale etc de
dire que la première digue de protection
si on essore complètement les
actionnaires ensuite c'est les
détenteurs de dettes subordonnée etc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les Suisses ils ont
protégé en partie certains actionnaires
qui étaient également enfin dont ils
assurent la gestion de fortune pour
certains soyons clairs donc donc c'était
et donc du coup gros problème sur la
dette bancaire subordonnée pour pour les
banques donc et puis de toute manière
soyons clairs aussi ces principes de
résolution le Belling le Belling peut
pas être appliqué en période de crise
sur une banque systémique c'est
impossible c'est un vecteur de diffusion
de la crise c'est un vecteur
d'accélération pourquoi on a instauré le
Belling bah c'est parce qu'on n'a pas
voulu imposer plus de capital de vrais
capitales aux banques c'est un espèce de
pseudo capitale qu'on active et on le
voit bien on l'a même pas activé pour
des bons petites pas au niveau
international donc là il y a un vrai
problème
et donc est-ce qu'on est plus protégé
quand on a avec une banque to be to safe
je dirais plus protégé oui parce que
parce que on la rend flou mais moi en
tant que contribuable je suis nettement
moins bien protégée quand j'ai des
banques systémiques parce que justement
elles vont être enflés et que ça peut et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça au moment de la
de l'Union bancaire qu'est-ce qu'on
avait pointé on avait pointé le cercle
vicieux entre dégradation de la notation
des états et dégradations de la note des
banques ça veut dire que les banques
parfois elles sont tellement grosses par
exemple si la notation de BNPP est
dégradée bah ça aura un impact direct
sur la notation de la France et de la
même manière si la notation de la France
est dégradée actuellement les marchés
s'en fichent de la dégradation mais
admettons qu'à un moment ça s'apprenne
et bien ça aura une influence sur la
notation des banques que l'État est
censé renflouer bon donc voilà alors
pour ce qui est de l'assurance dépôt à
250 000 dollars aux États-Unis et 100000
dollars en Europe il vous a pas échappé
que ça avait complètement sauté cette
histoire de 250000 euros et c'est 250000
dollars aux États-Unis c'est-à-dire SVB
on a on a assuré tous les dépôts y
compris des dépôts considérables de
l'ordre du millénaire il y a eu des
chiffres qui sont sortis en Suisse les
10 plus gros
déposants c'était plus de 13 milliards
de dollars sur on se dépôt qui assure à
ce niveau là alors c'est vrai que
maintenant ils essayent de faire payer
des plus grosses banques etc mais c'est
un vrai problème d'aller à moral et de
toute manière donc ne vous inquiétez pas
en cas de crise bancaire majeur
l'assurance dépôt saute faut pas trop le
dire mais on a surtout le monde pour
éviter de et c'est ce qu'on a fait dans
toutes les crises la banque la crise
bancaire japonaise enfin c'est ce qu'on
fait tout le temps donc donc voilà
alors pour les histoires de banque de
petite taille moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord je pense que un système
bancaire qui est plus modulaire
d'ailleurs la théorie des systèmes nous
dit ça y compris en physique les
systèmes les plus résilients c'est les
systèmes qui sont modulaires c'est à
dire qu'ils peuvent se réaménager suite
à un choc il a rien de moins modulaire
qu'un système bancaire qui est dominé
par quatre grosses banques qui ont
finalement des tailles de bilan
tellement grandes qui sont une
approximation du marché ça veut dire
qu'elles sont hyper exposées à ce qu'on
appelle le risque systématique c'est à
dire justement les expositions communes
alors que des petites banques j'ai rien
contre la banque universelle j'ai
quelque chose contre la banque universel
qui lit les mains des États qui les
oblige à renflouer mais des petites
banques universelles font la même chose
finance plus et ça je m'appuie sur des
études académiques qui ont été faites il
y a une énorme discontinuité entre le
comment dire le modèle d'activité d'une
banque universelle de plus petite taille
de grandes barres de plus grande taille
plus elles sont grosses moins finance au
vrai sens du terme c'est-à-dire plus
elles font des activités de marché en
réalité
et donc la ça veut dire pas dans
l'absolu elle finance pas moins dans
l'absolu mais relativement leur taille
de bilan bon et en plus de ça elle nous
met plus en risque donc moi je pense
qu'on a raté une occasion lors de la loi
bancaire de 2013 parce que c'était un
bon moyen de ne pas protéger des
activités qui ne doivent pas l'être les
activités de marché alors actuellement
des dans un système où on protège tout y
compris les activités de marché y
compris comment il y a une mauvaise
gestion comme dans le cas de crédit
Suisse alors qu'en fait il faudrait que
la seule activité qui soit protégée ce
soit les activités de près au PME au
ménage c'est à ceux qui n'ont pas de
solution alternative pour se financer
pour ce qui est de la tribune de
Jean-Marc vittory sur la responsabilité
personnelle des banquiers j'avais
moi-même défendu cette idée et et
il y a quelque chose de très
symptomatique quand les banques
d'investissements américaine sont pas su
du statut de partnership au statut de
société anonyme la prise de risque elle
a considérablement augmenté évidemment
quand vous avez pas votre partenaire
c'est vous qui assumez des pertes vous
êtes vous êtes responsable y compris
pour l'endettement de et donc le modèle
d'activité a radicalement changé donc ça
ça va dans le sens effectivement il y a
plus de prise de risque quand vous
n'êtes pas responsable et puis quelque
chose qui est très symptomatique c'est
le mouvement qu'on a connu dans la
plupart des économies de dépénalisation
de la vie des affaires c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui si une banque fait une
grosse bêtise si je sais pas moi au
hasard elle finance un état génocidaire
ou à l'organisme de la fuite fiscale
bande organisée ou si elle manipule le
lit bon le Tibor le rebord le Forex je
ne sais quoi bref il y aura des amendes
les amandes c'est pas ceux qui ont pris
les décisions qui les payent les amendes
c'est la société anonyme vous créez une
distance alors que si vous voulez le sac
de la petite vieille à côté là c'est
vous directement parce que vous êtes il
y a il y a pas une espèce de comment
dire de de caractère abstrait de la
faute évidemment les comment dire les
sommes en jeu ce que doit payer la
collectivité et c'est sans commune
mesure donc cette dépénalisation de la
vie des affaires elle est très
importante parce que c'est quoi le pénal
ça c'est un juriste qui me l'a expliqué
je ne le savais pas le pénal c'est ce
qui vous dit dans une société la ligne
jaune si je le dépasse je passe ça veut
dire que c'est une trouble c'est un
trouble à la comment dire à la cohésion
sociale si vous dépénalisez la vie des
affaires ça veut dire que vous
considérez que faire de je sais pas moi
de enfin tout ce que j'ai dit là toutes
les fraudes financières ce n'est pas un
trouble majeur donc ça veut dire que les
signaux que vous envoyez c'est que c'est
moins grave que de voler le sac de voilà
bon donc ça ça c'est très symptomatique
en fait de de nos sociétés et je pense
qu'on devrait repénaliser un certain
nombre de choses et re responsabiliser
j'ai pas des interdictions d'exercer pas
forcément des choses mais par exemple le
stigmate de l'interdiction d'exercer ça
serait déjà quelque chose voilà bon
alors je sais pas trop quoi vous dire
encore j'ai plein d'autres choses à vous
dire mais bon je sais que je sais que
j'ai pas le temps donc j'arrête alors
merci mes camarades merci beaucoup alors
mai à tigre pour les questions qui vous
paraissent relever
merci beaucoup pour pour l'ensemble de
ces questions j'ai essayé de
synthétiser les réponses et peut-être
pour rebondir sur tout l'exposé de
Madame Scialom avec toute la chaleur
dont elle a fait preuve je pense que
tout serait totalement vrai si en fait
les banques étaient désorganismes
totalement statique et à la fois
statique statique dans les livres dans
les études etc et hermétique au monde
extérieur alors je vais peut-être partir
du dernier point que vous avez cité qui
est la dépénalisation du droit des
affaires est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est agréable quand votre banque
quand votre entité quand l'Antiquité que
vous dirigez parfois que vous avez fondé
on parle de droit des affaires de
manière générale est-ce que c'est
agréable qu'elle soit mise en cause dans
des questions dans des affaires pénales
est-ce que c'est agréable que son nom
soit site ça n'est nullement agréable ce
n'est pas neutre voilà ce n'est pas
notre ce n'est ni agréable ni neutre et
donc le stigma il existe aujourd'hui je
tiens à le dire
extrêmement solennellement car ce n'est
pas un sujet de règle pénale ou autre si
les banques sont hermétiques à l'image
qu'elle renvoie à la société à la
relation avec le juge à la relation avec
les autorités et qu'elle dise allègement
fiche je franchis la ligne rouge et
advienne que pourra que sera sera si
vous voulez non ça ne marche pas comme
ça la vie voilà la vie même en dehors
des bouquins on fait attention aux
risques on fait attention à ce qu'on
fait alors je le dis de cette manière
parce qu'en fait au fond tout ce qu'on a
cité comme risque ce sont des choses qui
sont connues parce que les académiques
en parlent parce qu'il y a des articles
parce que vous êtes interpellé dans la
rue vous êtes interpellé par Jean que
vous connaissez vous êtes interpellé
parfois par vos salariés vous avez des
superviseurs Evelyne Macé a dit intrusif
vous avez des équipes de parfois des
dizaines de personnes qui viennent chez
vous pendant de multiples semaines qui
vous posent toutes sortes de questions
qu'on comprenaient même pas la question
vous la travaillez et puis vous vous
dites est-ce que la question avait une
justification ce que j'ai fait et puis
non pas dire ouh là là ils ont dit qu'il
y avait un risque là-dessus non c'est
pas ça la réaction la réaction c'est de
dire comment est-ce que j'explique ce
risque est-ce que je l'ai compris et le
premier réflexe quand on ne comprend pas
c'est d'essayer de comprendre de trouver
les données et ensuite d'échanger et de
voir comment on le gère parce que vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président
effectivement il y aurait un moyen très
simple de d'arrêter tout ça c'est
effectivement de ne plus prêter à
personne et puis tant pis c'est comme ça
les héritiers pourront dans un monde
sans banque acheter un logement avec ce
que leur parents leur ont légué et puis
les autres et bien ils attendront un
autre monde et donc en tout cas ce que
je veux dire c'est que au fond ce que ce
que ce que montre cet échange peut-être
c'est que ce n'est pas la réglementation
seule ni la supervision seule ni la
qualité de gestion interne qui fait
qu'on passe les crises et
c'est une capacité collective aussi à y
faire face et je vais rebondir sur ce
que vous avez dit
sur cette question de propos qui selon
vous ne répondez pas à la question en
fait la première étape chaque fois qu'il
y a une crise ou une inquiétude sur un
établissement c'est de dire mais quelle
est l'exposition des autres
établissements à celui-là et c'est vrai
que tout ce qui a été fait depuis 2008
cette couper les liens pas seulement du
fait des banques centrales mais de
couper les liens et en tout cas d'éviter
qu'il y ait une concentration ou une
exposition importante ce qui fait que
tout naturellement quand il y a un
établissement californien qui a une
difficulté le lendemain on dit tiens
est-ce qu'on le connaît ce qu'on a une
contagion mécanique et ça d'une certaine
manière la réponse est légitime il se
trouve que au moment où la réponse est
faite en réalité le sujet s'est étendu à
d'autres et donc la réponse devient
insuffisante néanmoins moi j'insiste sur
la démarche et nous l'avons vécu
ensemble d'ailleurs au moment de la
crise covid au moment de la crise
ukrainienne la démarche de gestion d'une
crise ce n'est pas juste le livre les
études et les dizaines milliers
centaines de pages auxquelles je faisais
référence c'est ça aussi parce que ça
donne un guide mais c'est aussi la
capacité qu'on a à se passer des coups
de fil à gérer le sujet à à la fois
élaborer des dispositifs faire en sorte
qu'ils soient géré correctement dans le
temps les ajuster je crois que nous
l'avons fait par exemple sur le pré avec
la garantie de l'État là sur une échelle
macroéconomique en faisant en sorte de
répondre progressivement et en combinant
je réponds de la même manière à Madame
vermeiller en essayant de concilier le
fait qu'il ne faut pas prendre de
risques inconsidéré le fait que quand
vous prenez des risques ça vous coûte et
c'est bien normal et le fait que à la
fin ce qui compte c'est que votre banque
soit pérenne c'est-à-dire qu'elle
continue à accompagner les clients
au-delà et donc vous essayez de combiner
ces trois choses le fait que vous
développez votre activité le fait que
vous avez un risque à gérer et que pour
assurer votre pérennité et donc
développer votre activité pouvoir mieux
gérer vous devez générer des profits et
je crois que c'est cette boucle activité
gestion du risque résultat profit et
c'est une boucle qui qui
fonctionne avec des paramètres
différents selon les banques et c'est
toute la valeur de leur modèle
d'affaires c'est à chacune de la définir
de bien la connaître d'en être
consciente y compris lors d'entretien
musclé avec les superviseurs et en fait
cette cette marge de manœuvre-là chacun
la définit à son niveau certains en ont
plus que d'autres mais en pratique
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est vraiment
cette transparence là et ces jeux de
données je vous invite vraiment à
regarder le rapport de la CPR qui
contient mais une base de une banque de
données absolument considérable sur les
banques bien au-delà du simple LCR et
cet et ce ne sont pas les seuls éléments
que les banques regardent pour dire
tiens je suis tranquille je suis en haut
je suis dans la moyenne je suis ceci je
suis cela non c'est une somme du tout et
c'est un peu une gestion quotidienne qui
conduit à le faire donc voilà je dirais
la gestion de la crise la capacité à
gérer la crise et c'est ce que nous
essayons de voir c'est vraiment cette
forme de confiance et ne pas se reposer
sur le fait qu'on a bien géré la
précédente mais s'assurer qu'on a bien
peut changer entre nous les éléments et
fait la transparence et je crois que
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un exercice
de transparence autour d'un objectif
commun qui est de faire en sorte que la
résilience de notre système bancaire
français en fait elle soit établie elle
donne confiance et que effectivement
s'il y a des turbulences boursières etc
on passe au-dessus alors ça c'est sur
l'aspect je dirais entre nous en
français en Europe ensuite sur
l'international et puis hors du secteur
bancaire alors je partage complètement
l'inquiétude de Monsieur Bocquet et
l'inquiétude de Monsieur Raynal sur les
secteurs non régulés d'autres également
monsieur Segoin monsieur qui a pu vous
avez parlé des crypto monnaie nous
sommes régulièrement l'objet
probablement après cette audition
également de très nombreux tweets
commentaires etc caricatures en
expliquant les banques complètement
ringardes alors que les crypto c'est
l'avenir etc
et nous sommes extrêmement ferme dans
toutes nos prises de position pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de secteur non réguler que
cette régulation soit sérieuse correcte
et qu'elle soit faite également dans les
détails de manière qualitative donc je
partage votre inquiétude sur les
secteurs non régulés à la fois au plan
international parce que cet agenda du
G20 soit il continue à être développé
dans des instances internationales mais
des pays ne l'appliquent pas soit
effectivement dans le domaine des
crypto-monnaies on a une différence de
règle qui est liée à la volonté de
stimuler l'innovation mais c'est un vrai
problème et c'est un enjeu de
concurrence aussi et là j'en viens je
ressors je dirais du domaine des crypto
pour revenir au domaine purement
bancaire je le redis sur les normes de
balles trois complétées elles ont été
négociées à Bâle beaucoup sur des
schémas d'autres me contesteront
peut-être mais beaucoup sur des schémas
de fonctionnement américain en tout cas
anglo-saxons dont nous considérons que
les déviations que madame cialome a
critiqué les déviations en Europe seront
liées tout simplement au fait que le
modèle européen comporte un certain
nombre de différences ce qui fait que
des risques européen vont être
surcalibrés et d'autres vont être sous
calibrées donc ce qu'on demande comme
l'Europe est quand même le bon élève
dans cette affaire nous négocions ce
texte depuis quatre ans aux États-Unis
il n'y a pas l'ombre du début de la
queue d'une transposition ça aussi je le
dis très solennellement il y a pas le
début du commencement de la part des
autorités d'un texte de transposition de
balle et nous entendons que nous allons
passer pour les mauvais élèves
internationaux à Bâle ce n'est pas
acceptable ce n'est tout simplement pas
acceptable ce que nous demandons c'est
que ces règles bâloises elles soient
finalisées
adoptée avec en veillant je me regarde
de nouveau madame merveilleux en
veillant à ce que leur impact sur je
dirais sur l'économie sur la réalité de
l'économie européenne encore une fois si
le résultat du texte c'est que il n'y a
plus aucune banque européenne dans le
secteur des marchés financiers et que en
Europe on ne propose plus que des taux
variables plutôt que des taux fixes et
ben on aura gagné effectivement je sais
pas si le citoyen européen aura gagné on
aura peut-être une bonne note à Bâle je
suis pas sûr qu'on aura une bonne note
vis-à-vis des citoyens européens donc
voilà ce qu'on demande c'est que cette
analyse risque adaptation soit bien
faite toujours avec des risques bien
gérés mais les vrais risques et pas des
risques un peu théorisés internationaux
voilà donc sur balle je je pense que ça
c'est un élément qui est important pour
bien éclairer le fait qu'on ne souhaite
pas que les textes soient appliqués à la
lettre comme ça on souhaite que des
textes soient appliqués mais avec les
quelques adaptations qui évitent de
faire éclater un modèle économique sur
la question de la banque assurance
d'ailleurs nous avons ce même type
d'enjeu puisque c'est un modèle peu
connu parfois critiqué stigmatisé même
alors qu'il apporte une valeur et donc
là encore je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
d'explications à apporter toujours pour
dire nous sommes d'accord pour que les
risques soient gérés mais nous ne
voulons pas que la gestion des risques
conduise à détruire un modèle donc il y
a vraiment un équilibre à trouver pour
que des produits continuent à être
offerts et je le redis tout ce qui est
écrit dans les livres serait vrai s'il
n'y avait pas d'adaptation or
généralement quand une activité devient
trop coûteuse l'adaptation est très
simple vous arrêtez de l'exercer voilà
je termine juste sur un point pardon qui
est celui de la taille des banques alors
en France il y a 10 groupes je dirais 10
groupes 10 pas les 5 ou 6 que dont vous
entendez le nom tous les jours mais 10
groupes qui représentent
86% de l'activité donc on n'est pas dans
un monde écrasé par les 10 premiers
parce que déjà chacun des 10 n'a pas la
totalité et les parts de marché peuvent
fortement varier d'un secteur à l'autre
et je crois qu'on peut s'émergueillir et
ça c'est une spécificité économique dont
nous pouvons nous satisfaire qui est
qu'on a un secteur à la fois avec
relativement peu d'acteurs mais très en
concurrence entre eux et donc au fond le
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
équilibrant et donc la place pour les
autres aujourd'hui les autres banques
hors de ces secteurs prennent 14% de la
place entre guillemets ce qui est déjà
je veux dire significatif c'est
certainement peut-être plus que ce qu'on
penserait spontanément moi-même j'ai
vérifié le chiffre dans le fameux
rapport de la CPR je ne l'avais pas en
tête et donc je pense que cet équilibre
entre grand petit et aussi le fait que à
l'intérieur de chacun des grands groupes
vous avez des logiques entrepreneuriales
qui font que vous allez avoir des
petites entités à l'intérieur des grands
groupes c'est quelque chose qui doit
vraiment je pense être préservés dans
notre modèle qui présente beaucoup de
vertus voilà et un tout dernier chiffre
pour la route l'exposition souveraine
puisque madame sialom faisait référence
à toute ce sujet la boucle souverain etc
etc on est autour de 6% des expositions
souveraines domestiques c'est-à-dire
pour la France par rapport au total des
actifs des banques françaises voilà donc
on est à 6%, je sais pas si on a été
plus à un moment mais enfin bon on est
on est en tout cas un niveau tout à fait
raisonnable
en termes de de boucle souverain
domestique
merci madame
je vais vous proposer si vous le voulez
bien madame de changer si vous acceptez
de passer un quatrième et dernière
d'abord parce que pour laisser une
petite place à un homme et et
simplement parce que Monsieur doit nous
quitter à midi pile donc je vais lui
demander de nous apporter ces termes de
conclusion merci monsieur le Président
et merci
Monsieur
vapeurs beaucoup de choses ont été dites
et beaucoup de questions sont posées je
voudrais revenir d'abord sur la première
question sommes-nous à l'abri cette
fois-ci est-elle différente notre
message est clair le point de départ est
solide mais nous sommes dans un contexte
qui va se traduire par ralentissement
économique qui peut être fort et donc
les banques effectivement vont être
affectées du fait de leurs actifs et
potentiellement aussi de lors de leur
passif et donc la question se pose
effectivement de savoir comment elles
vont absorber cela nous pensons que le
point de départ est solide mais il peut
aussi y avoir des effets secondaires qui
être ceux en fait qui proviennent
également de la finance non régulée
telle que nous l'avions vu déjà à
l'automne au Royaume-Uni avec le petit à
coup sur le marché de la dette
britannique tel que nous l'avons vu
aussi avec ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis où il y a des phénomènes de
contagion qui ont été certes de courte
durée mais qui existent donc nous ne
savons nous ne sommes pas dans un
message dans mes ampères tout va bien
nous sommes dans un message de vigilance
le une banque prend des risques je vous
rejoins tout à fait sur ce sujet là une
banque est là pour prendre des risques
et la réglementation est agnostique sur
le sujet elle ne cherche pas à ce que la
banque soit uniquement exposée à taux
variables au contraire la banque est là
pour faire de la transformation c'est la
raison d'être de la banque c'est la
raison d'être aussi de la réglementation
donc une banque prend des risques les
règles et ce qui compte c'est donc la
qualité de la gestion de son actif et de
son passif par cette banque les règles
ont été durci depuis la dernière crise
et à nouveau à l'automne avec la
perspective de ce qui allait se produire
du fait de la remontée des taux
l'Autorité bancaire a publié des règles
durci sur la gestion du risque de taux
dans les bilans bancaire à l'automne
dernier qui ont parfois été d'ailleurs
l'objet de certaines critiques
contestation creederfrais dans le dans
le marché mais qui sont là précisément
pour protéger les banques et leur et
leurs clients alors y a-t-il et donc
nous faisons cela de manière parce qu'il
y a à la fois l'impact de cette remontée
des taux sur la marge de taux mais aussi
l'impact sur l'ensemble du bilan ce
qu'on appelle la méthode d'évaluation en
fait sur l'impact sur l'action en fait
la valeur de l'action d'une banque ou on
réévalue chaque poste de bilan actif
passif pour voir comment comment elle
résiste à leur monter des taux juste
après et donc les détails vont être vont
être publiés
du stress test en juillet avec un une
présentation sectorielle des expositions
le scénario du stress test comprend
justement une remontée des taux très
dures
la votre question y a-t-il un seuil
limite en fait la question dépend d'une
banque à l'autre parce que change d'une
banque à l'autre parce que les banques
ont des gestion de encore une fois de
actif passifs différentes elle se couvre
différemment selon leur activité elles
sont plus ou moins exposées à certains
secteurs à certaines durations elles ont
des stratégies de couverture aussi
différentes donc il n'y a pas une
réponse simple et unique mais il faut
évidemment que le superviseur fasse son
travail pour évaluer tout cela donc nous
avons un travail en cours là-dessus qui
devrait produire ses effets le les
règles de base alors ont été très
largement évoquées je crois que l'Union
européenne a cherché cherche une voie
alors elle est effectivement aujourd'hui
très très non conforme l'Union
européenne aux règles de base et donc
elle a été jugée comme tel donc je pense
qu'on peut pas dire que l'Union
européenne s'est mise complètement dans
une logique qui soit celle de banque
anglo-saxonne sinon nous aurions été
jugés conformes d'autre part je ne pense
pas que les règles balles non plus
soient du tout la la candidat la
réflexion d'un modèle typiquement
anglo-saxon ce sont des discussions qui
cherchent à trouver une voie une voie
équilibrée le Béa non plus d'ailleurs ne
fait ne produit pas des milliers de
normes il y a certainement des milliers
de pages mais pas des milliers de normes
effectivement alors baltrom nous a
plutôt protégé jusqu'à présent baltrrois
notamment sur la question de la gestion
du risque de taux à protéger les les
banques européennes et leurs déposants
une partie du problème aux États-Unis
vient du fait qu'il n'avait pas mis en
oeuvre les règles de gestion de taux
demandé par balle
les mécanismes de contagion ont été
beaucoup évoqués certes il y a une des
risques depuis la dernière crise certes
il y a moins d'exposition interbancaires
il a fallu que ce soit cela aussi parce
que les banques ne voulaient plus prêter
entre elles donc la Banque centrale
européenne a dû s'intermédiaire d'une
certaine manière remplacer le marché ce
n'est pas uniquement le fait de la
réglementation c'était cette défiance
généralisée néanmoins il y a toujours
des mécanismes de contagion réels nous
les avons vu lors de la situation qui
s'est qui s'est produit aux États-Unis
et avec Crédit Suisse ne serait-ce que
parce que les banques sont exposées au
même actifs ou on peut avoir des
problèmes de passif similaires et puis
il y a aussi des questions de vente à
découvert il y a aussi le marché du CDS
le crédit des folles soient les échanges
de de risques de crédit nous avons vu
qu'il y a eu des mouvements spéculatifs
ce qui a frappé certaines banques
notamment notamment Dolce Bank et donc
comment répondre à cela mais je pense
qu'il faut pour que la marché puisse se
déployer et de façon normale et que la
spéculation n'est pas de n'est pas de
place il faut de la transparence et donc
il faut de la transparence il faut que
le marché soit convaincu qu'il a toute
l'information dont il a besoin pour se
faire son opinion et que la supervision
a réel et dans ce contexte c'est pour ça
que nous publions toutes toutes ces
informations à l'Autorité bancaire
européenne dans le cadre du stress test
dans le cas des exercices de
transparence que nous effectuons chaque
année donc ce que je voudrais dire
jusque à l'instant c'est que la digue a
tenu jusqu'à présent c'est ça qu'il faut
je regarde en tête la digue tenue mais
il est important de publier de
l'information il est important que le
marché puisse se faire son opinion
différencier c'est pour ça aussi que
nous avons fait un communiqué avec les
superviseurs le matin de la résolution
fin de la résolution de
la gestion du problème de crédit Suisse
par les autorités pour dire que la
question des des obligations AT1
additionnel tiroir qui avait été
maltraité en Suisse ou en tout cas qui
avait été très très différent ne vous
n'aurez pas pu être traité dans les
mêmes conditions en Europe nous avons
très communiqué très clairement là
dessus je pense que cela contribuait
fortement à rassurer
il y a des questions à se poser
effectivement sur la vitesse de retrait
des dépôts nous sommes entrés dans un
nouveau monde avec des applications
numériques qui permettent aux gens de
faire de transférer leur dépôt beaucoup
plus vite qu'avant donc les réflexions
ont commencé sur le sujet la question de
l'Université des dirigeants se posent
pas seulement lors de leur nomination en
Europe il y a des examens quand il se
passe quelque chose dans une banque
l'honorabilité des dirigeants peut être
réexaminé et examiné par la Banque
centrale européenne et les autorités
nationales il y a des exemples pas
public mais il y a des exemples et ça
cela se fait la garantie des dépôts à
100.000 euros est-elle suffisante alors
en fait aux États-Unis ce qui s'est
passé c'est que c'était des dépôts non
garantie et donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont qu'ils sont qui sont partis très
largement il n'y a pas de seuil idéal je
pense mais 100000 euros paraît quand
même un bon un niveau compte tenu de la
de la de la de la nature et de la
composition de ces de ces déposants une
question a été posée sur l'endettement
elle élevée en France et l'accès au
logement je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec cette question la question de
l'endettement effectivement est une
fragilité dans dans ce pays de l'Union
européenne forte les règles
prudentielles dans les autres pays ne
sont pas forcément
meilleur le fait que les ménages soient
endettés à taux variables au contraire
les exposent d'autant plus donc je pense
que le fait que les ménages soient
exposés très largement à taux fixe en
France est plutôt une bonne sécurité le
fait que l'eau conseiller de la
stabilité financière est aussi contribue
à renforcer ses règles qui sont
calculées sur la capacité des ménage à
rembourser leur dette est plutôt un
facteur de sécurité aussi parce que ça
ça protège dans un contexte de remontée
des taux cela protège très fortement les
ménages et effectivement cela force les
banques à avoir une gestion de risque de
taux adapté c'est évident la taille des
banques nous l'avons vu SVB était assez
petite Crédit Suisse est très grosse
donc effectivement une crise bancaire
peut survenir quel que soit la taille de
la de la banque enfin peut-être sur la
question des des marchés crypto et des
marchés non réglementés mais des cryptos
en particulier jusqu'à présent
l'activité des banques dans ce domaine
est assez réduite d'une manière générale
en Europe les banques sont assez
demandeuses d'aller sur ces sur ces
créneaux ne serait-ce que parce qu'il y
a de la demande de la part de leurs
clients et qu'elle voit qu'il y a du
potentiel le canal contagieux a plutôt
été inverse cette fois-ci c'est plutôt
les les acteurs du monde crypto qui ont
été affectés par la situation de banques
des banques dont ils avaient besoin pour
pour certaines de leurs transactions il
y a un règlement européen qui vient
d'être adopté en Europe qui s'appelle
mikar
marketing crypto à 7 qui va apporter un
cadre réglementaire pour les émetteurs
de d'actifs crypto donc ça c'est très
positif ça va permettre aux
investisseurs de faire la différence de
savoir avec quel exactement type
d'intervenants il travaille et il va y
avoir un cadre réglementaire qui va
s'appliquer sur la plupart des émetteurs
de d'actifs crypto je m'arrête là
merci Monsieur Michaud et nous vous
excusons si vous devez nous quitter
et merci d'être venu madame massé donc à
la fois sur les questions qui vous
passent nécessité une réponse de votre
part et quelques mots de conclusion
finalement merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président et merci à tous pour pour vos
questions donc je pense que je vais
essayer de m'inscrire en complément
notamment des propos de François Louis
Michaud que je pars tout à fait en
particulier en termes de vigilance que
nous exerçons actuellement étant donné
le contexte schématiquement la contagion
peut s'exercer je dirais par plusieurs
canaux alors le premier c'est le canal
direct un peu simpliste est-ce que j'ai
voilà une exposition directe sur la
l'établissement problématique le
deuxième canal c'est je suis dans une
situation similaire donc a priori
peut-être que je vais te confronter au
même problème et puis le dernier canal
c'est finalement la crise de confiance
c'est à dire dis une situation plus
tendue qui fait que bon ben voilà si on
est déjà un petit peu dans une situation
limite on va pouvoir rencontrer des
obstacles supérieurs à voilà ce qu'on
avait juste ici et donc voir même gérer
se trouver en difficulté j'ai envie de
dire
c'est pour ça qu'on est très vigilant
c'est plutôt en lien avec ce troisième
effet
donc je pense que le propos de mon
exposé c'est déjà au moins de vous
rassurer sur peut-être les deux
premières parties et de vous dire sur la
voilà le dernier effet qui est un effet
très psychologique
voilà on est on est en alerte on est en
alerte et finalement on capitalise sur
l'énorme travail d'analyse qu'on mène au
quotidien pour bien connaître gérer les
éventuels vulnérabilités des uns et des
autres pour être sûr d'être d'anticiper
et qui sont en capacité de gérer leur
risque efficacement c'est là-dessus que
j'aimerais peut-être aussi répondre à la
question de monsieur le Président sur
alors on est tout à fait d'accord je sur
le l'importance que balle proie soit
appliqué partout y compris chez nos amis
américains
au comité de balle on œuvre activement
aux côtés de nos autres collègues
superviseurs pour je dirais bien
rappeler que le problème a commencé de
l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
néanmoins comme vous le savez c'est
c'est un processus compliqué législatif
de leur côté aussi donc on forme les
vœux de mettre la pression au maximale
je dirais dans le domaine de la
supervision à notre niveau en espérant
que les turbulences récentes qui quand
même représentent une vraie menace pour
pour l'économie américaine
donne l'impulsion politique pour aller
de l'avant même si c'est pas facile
alors je voudrais quand même souligner
le fait que c'est pas juste une
satisfaction morale de mettre en oeuvre
le cadre on va dire dans ces principes
de façon rigoureuse au niveau européen
alors effectivement on a certaines
petites adaptations mais quand même dans
l'ensemble les principes clés on les met
en oeuvre d'où toutes ces générations on
va dire de mise à niveau du cadre
européen que François Louis Michaud nous
a présenté
dans son exposé liminaire c'est pas
juste une satisfaction morale ça a
vraiment considérablement renforcé la
gestion des risques des établissements
il y a un vrai changement de culture de
vraies adaptation donc grâce à ces
évolutions je pense que nos
établissements ont été et j'ai donné
quelques exemples parmi d'autres parce
que une banque est exposée à une
multiplicie de risques comme vous l'avez
rappelé c'est grâce à ces évolutions qui
ont été ils ont été en mesure de mieux
gérer
la remontée la remontée des taux
notamment et d'anticiper l'évolution de
la politique monétaire notamment en fin
d'année dernière nous établissements
français ils ont été amenés à rembourser
133 milliards au titre de l'opération
voilà de la BCE qui s'appelle tltaro 3
désolé pour le nom barbare mais en gros
ils ont pas attendu ils ont anticipé en
début d'année ils avaient déjà réalisé
plus de 60 plus des trois quarts en fait
de leur programme de financement
voilà donc ça je crois qu'il faut
vraiment se dire ça va au-delà de la
moralité c'est une réelle utilité alors
vous nous avez demandé aussi si on
appliquait le cadre notamment la loi
srab je tiens à souligner oui nous
veillons à son application alors dès
après
j'irai l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
bancaire il y a une série de contrôle
sur place des recommandations formulées
aux établissements et depuis on suit en
contrôle permanent il y a eu deux
nouveaux des contrôles sur place pour
suivre la mise en oeuvre donc c'est bien
suivi
s'agissant de la gouvernance en général
on a parlé de l'honorabilité la
compétence des dirigeants plus
généralement le contrôle des risques
c'est une c'est vraiment une très
importante priorité de supervision pour
nous en fait dans notre grille d'analyse
des risques en tant que superviseur pour
tout vous dire on compte autant ce qu'on
appelle l'exposition intrinsèque au
risque et le dispositif de maîtrise de
risque de chaque établissement ça compte
autant parce que bien évidemment et
c'est ce que rappelait Maya TIG une
banque c'est pas un objet statique voilà
il doit être proactif il doit prendre en
main sa maîtrise des risques c'est
essentiel
alors en termes de noshabilité et de
compétences à cet égard le paquet
bancaire européen qui est en cours en
cours d'examen c'est CRD 6 et R3 inclus
encore un renforcement à cet égard et je
peux vous dire que dès à présent en lien
avec nos collègues de la Banque centrale
européenne nous portons une
attention extrême
à la qualité des dirigeants des
établissements c'est un point difficile
c'est un point dur mais on va jusqu'au
bout y compris au niveau de
l'actionnariat car ce qu'on dit le ton
du sommet c'est essentiel pour cette
culture des risques
alors peut-être pour répondre à une
petite question de monsieur le
rapporteur général sur pourquoi c'est
différent en assurance c'est une
excellente c'est une question très
intéressante
je pense peut-être un point important à
rappeler c'est que le modèle d'activité
d'un soir et est différente on dit qu'il
y a inversion du cycle de production
pourquoi parce que l'assureur perçoit
des primes et puis des fois c'est pas du
tout s'il y a pas de sinistre des fois
c'est très longtemps après si on regarde
des produits de retraite il va régler
une prestation donc naturellement en
fait il est plutôt pourvoyeur de
liquidité que demandeur de liquidité
alors vous me direz il y a l'assurance
vie de type et là voilà on pourrait
voilà ça peut ressembler un petit peu à
des problématiques qu'on a sur les
dépôts mais encore faut-il que voilà on
est des alternatives géré pour placer
son épargne par ailleurs c'est assez
assez compliqué comme comme dynamique
toujours est-il que voilà en moyenne le
risque de liquidité chez un assureur il
est très différent finalement de celui
du d'une banque et côté risque de taux
je tiens à souligner que mais bien sûr
c'est enfin c'est un risque fondamental
pour un assureur le risque de taux et
dans le cadre de Solvabilité 2 il y a
bien en fait dans le calcul des
exigences de capital même si selon des
modalités un petit peu différentes il y
a bien des chocs de taux qui sont
appliquées de gérer tout à fait
comparable voire même beaucoup plus
sophistiqué que ce qu'on a dans le cadre
du du cadre bancaire
je vous dis revenir aussi brièvement sur
voilà les notamment les propos du du
sénateur va cherche sur voilà la
problématique d'endettement j'ai quand
même à rappeler de nouveau qui est
effectivement le là de notre point de
vue le comité de s'habitais financière
via gérer les normes macro prudentielles
qui ont été adoptées sur ces thématiques
alors qu'il s'agisse effectivement côté
ménage des normes de d'octroi des
crédits immobiliers ou tout ce qui
relève de l'article 458 sur les grands
risques voilà justement bien pris en
considération ces problématiques pour
assurer la stabilité du système les
difficultés rencontrées à l'octroi ces
derniers mois étaient de notre point de
vue plus lié à une peut-être une
problématique du taux d'usure qui depuis
a été voilà il y avait une problématique
un peu de phase de transition et puis je
dirais ça a été ça a été pris en charge
par les pouvoirs publics l'examen de
cette question et que normalement voilà
on a un petit peu sorti d'affaires à ce
propos
je voulais revenir également et appuyer
les propos je crois de tous les
intervenants sur l'importance de porter
une intention forte sur la
réglementation enfin
sur le secteur non régulé effectivement
le règlement Mika en cours d'adoption
par la Commission européenne et une très
bonne nouvelle de notre de notre point
de vue et je ne voulais pas passer sous
les silence les enjeux
climatiques et environnementaux je tiens
quand même vraiment à appuyer le fait
que ces deux notes de point de vue une
priorité également alors après c'est un
chemin un chemin à parcourir ensemble il
y a un temps un temps d'adaptation
des fin 2020 la Banque centrale
européenne dans le cadre du mécanisme de
supervision unique a publié des attentes
de supervision en la matière il y a eu
deux exercices de revue thématique
menées auprès des établissements suivis
par le MSU sur comment il mettait en
œuvre ses principes quel était leur
feuille de route pour
s'y conformer
à l'issue de la deuxième revue il y a
des voilà toute une série de bonnes
pratiques qui ont fait l'objet d'une
publication
en fin d'année dernière je tombe pour
illustrer comment on peut mettre en
oeuvre voilà activement dans sa gestion
des risques la prise en compte des
enjeux climatiques et environnementaux
il nous semble que là aussi le paquet
bancaire qui est sur la table ouvre
également la voix sur cette thématique
de notre côté on croit plus à au plan de
transition comme un homme bonne outil de
dialogue et de suivi des progrès des
établissements bancaires en la matière
c'est effectivement on n'est pas
exactement dans le même temps que une
crise immédiate de liquidité c'est un
enjeu de de transformation profonde
culturel et donc faut je reprends voilà
faut poser plusieurs jalons et suivre de
près les progrès de chaque étape et
c'est ce que nous voilà nous avons prévu
de faire avec nos collègues dans le
cadre du mécanisme supervision unique
pour tout vous dire des voilà notre
parce que tous les ans on fait une
évaluation du profil de risque de toutes
les banques
voilà dès cette année on va commencer à
prendre activement en compte ces
éléments de prise en compte des enjeux
climatiques environnementaux dans le
dispositif de gestion des risques et
dépend
sur ce j'espère que j'ai ouvert les
questions voilà rapidement merci
beaucoup
merci Madame
nous arrivons donc au terme de cette
audition
nous avons je crois nous avions je crois
tous besoin
de VOUS réentendre sur ces sujets
à la fois comme tout le monde épargnant
pour nous rassurer
êtes-vous totalement parvenu je ne sais
pas enfin en tout cas vous avez donné
des éléments
importants merci
d'avoir bien voulu répondre à notre
invitation et merci pour la qualité de
vos interventions bonne fin de journée
au revoir